I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
我今年50岁了，你知道我度假时最不想做的事是什么吗？哦，大概有几件。我不想让全家人挤在同一个只有一间卧室和浴室的房间里。我不想。不。我不想我们所有人都挤在一起。我想要有自己的卧室，和孩子们分开，这就是我更喜欢爱彼迎（Airbnb）的原因。因为我们每个人都能有自己的空间，这会让整个假期变得更放松。我们可以不同时间睡觉。你知道，我可以熬夜看书，
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
或者最近更可能的情况是，我比其他人先睡。你知道我喜欢爱彼迎的什么吗？什么？零食。你有什么我喜欢爱彼迎的？什么？零食。你有冰箱，有厨房。所以我不用一直叫客房服务，也不用支付那笔费用。
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks. They're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. Air Transat presents two friends traveling in Europe for the first time and feeling some pretty big emotions. This coffee is so good. How do they make it so rich and tasty?
我只会说，嘿，我们带了零食。它们在冰箱里，去拿吧。好了，各位，考虑一下下次旅行选择爱彼迎吧。你不会后悔从传统酒店转投爱彼迎的。加拿大越洋航空（Air Transat）为您呈现两位朋友第一次在欧洲旅行，感受着相当强烈的情绪。这咖啡太好喝了。他们是怎么把它做得这么浓郁美味的？
Those paintings we saw today weren't prints. They were the actual paintings. I have never seen tomatoes like this. How are they so red? With flight deals starting at just $589, it's time for you to see what Europe has to offer. Don't worry, you can handle it. Visit airtransat.com for details, conditions apply.
我们今天看到的那些画不是印刷品。它们是真迹。我从来没见过这样的西红柿。它们怎么这么红？机票优惠低至589美元起，是时候去看看欧洲有什么好玩的了。别担心，你应付得来。详情请访问airtransat.com，适用相关条款。
Air Transat, travel moves us. Welcome back to Second Drink the Fight. This one was my assignment. I loved this episode and I had a lot of fun digging in for some second drink tidbits. I found some good stuff, lady. Well, I enjoyed this breakdown as well. You know, these were the early days of the podcast and we were trying to find new things. And one thing that I loved was when we decided to pick an office fan to read the weekly summary. This week was read by Alexis. So be on the lookout
加拿大越洋航空，旅行让我们前行。欢迎回到《第二杯》（Second Drink）的《打架》（The Fight）这一集。这一集是我的任务。我非常喜欢这一集，在挖掘一些“第二杯”花絮时我玩得很开心。我发现了一些好东西，女士。嗯，我也很喜欢这次解析。你知道，那是播客的早期阶段，我们正在尝试寻找新事物。我喜欢的一件事是，当我们决定挑选一位办公室粉丝来阅读每周摘要时。这一周是由亚历克西斯（Alexis）朗读的。所以请留意
for that. I feel like maybe we should bring that back somehow. I like this idea. We'll brainstorm. We'll think on it. Mm-hmm. Well, another thing that I loved about this episode is that, Angela, you reconnected with Lance Krall, who plays Sensei Ira.
那个部分。我觉得也许我们应该以某种方式把它带回来。我喜欢这个主意。我们会集思广益。我们会考虑一下。嗯。嗯，关于这一集我喜欢的另一件事是，安吉拉，你和饰演伊拉（Ira）教练的兰斯·克拉尔（Lance Krall）重新联系上了。
I did. And that brings me to some of the fun stuff I found in this week's second drink. So you know in the episode where we see Dwight doing the chores around the dojo? Well in the shooting draft, it listed a bunch of little moments that could fill out a montage. There was no dialogue, just Dwight cleaning,
是的。这让我想到了我在本周的“第二杯”中发现的一些有趣的事情。你知道在德怀特（Dwight）在道场做杂务的那一集吗？在拍摄剧本中，列出了一堆可以填充蒙太奇的小片段。没有对话，只有德怀特在打扫，
answering phones, et cetera. I think that Rain and Lance got to play around a little bit because there is a very funny deleted scene on the DVDs. It is not in the shooting draft. We didn't talk about it in our first re-watch, but it's in the super fan episode. It's really funny. I think we should hear it. Okay. Excellent. All right. That's okay. Hold on. Hold on. Sorry. Just one second. Dwight, you can't use your page here. I told you. Okay. Dwight, it's a sales call. 10 pushups. 10 pushups! I can, yes, Sensei.
接电话等等。我想雷恩（Rainn）和兰斯当时可以自由发挥，因为DVD上有一个非常有趣的删减片段。它不在拍摄剧本里。我们在第一次重温时没有谈论它，但它在超级粉丝版剧集中。它真的很有趣。我觉得我们应该听听。好的。太棒了。好吧。没关系。等等。等等。抱歉。就一秒钟。德怀特，你不能在这里用你的传呼机。我告诉过你了。好的。德怀特，这是个销售电话。做10个俯卧撑。10个俯卧撑！我可以，是的，教练。
I mean, I feel like they just turned on the camera and said, guys, go for it. Just mess around. Yeah. Well, and Lance is such a talented guy. You know, I talked about how much I loved Lance from the Joe Schmo show, and I talk about how I auditioned for it,
我的意思是，我觉得他们只是打开了摄像机，然后说，伙计们，开始吧。随便玩玩。是的。而且兰斯是一个非常有才华的人。你知道，我谈到过我有多喜欢《乔·施莫秀》（Joe Schmo Show）里的兰斯，我还谈到过我是如何为它试镜的，
I did not get the role, and I was positive that this was an Alison Jones project. And that's how she knew about Lance. I know, but we got some fan mail. We did. From guess who? Rhett Reese, the co-creator of Joe Schmoe, who said, Jenna, your memory is a touch off.
我没得到那个角色，而且我确信这是艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones）的项目。这就是她了解兰斯的方式。我知道，但我们收到了一些粉丝来信。我们确实收到了。猜猜是谁写的？《乔·施莫秀》的联合创作者雷特·里斯（Rhett Reese），他说，珍娜（Jenna），你的记忆有点偏差。
Pat Melton cast Joe Schmoe for us, not Alison Jones, but thanks so much for the kind shout out. Rhett, thank you for writing in. Yes, but Rhett, why didn't I get a part? What did I do right, buddy? You're stirring the pot. I am. Well, you know, I think we should have Lance on because we never got a chance to talk to him about being in Junior Salesman in season 9.
是帕特·梅尔顿（Pat Melton）为我们选角《乔·施莫秀》，不是艾莉森·琼斯，但非常感谢你的好意提及。雷特，谢谢你写信来。是的，但是雷特，为什么我没得到角色？我做对了什么，伙计？你在煽风点火。我是。嗯，你知道，我觉得我们应该请兰斯来，因为我们从来没有机会和他谈谈他在第九季《初级推销员》（Junior Salesman）里的表现。
Well, I would love to get an insider's take on all those scenes of all those guys. Right? Together doing their interview. That would be fun. That would be fun. Well to wrap up my second drinks tidbit section here, I have a little scene in the accounting nook I want to share and then I have some really delicious candy bag alts. Okay. First of all, there was a great scene over in accounting. We did not discuss it. It's in the deleted scenes,
嗯，我很想听听他对那些家伙所有场景的内部看法。对吧？一起做采访。那会很有趣。那会很有趣。好了，为了结束我的“第二杯”花絮部分，我有一个会计角落的小场景想分享，然后我有一些非常美味的糖果袋替代方案。好的。首先，会计部有一个很棒的场景。我们没有讨论过。它在删减片段里，
and it's also in the super fan episode, but it's one of those moments over in accounting that really shows the dynamic between Oscar, Angela and Kevin. I always loved doing those scenes. And in this one, Angela's a little hangry. Oh, yeah. She's waiting for Michael to sign all of the expense reports, and she thinks that Oscar might have taken her snack. It cracked me up. Let's hear it.
它也在超级粉丝版剧集中，但这是会计部里那些真正展现奥斯卡（Oscar）、安吉拉和凯文（Kevin）之间动态的时刻之一。我一直很喜欢演那些场景。在这一段里，安吉拉有点“饿怒”（hangry）。哦，是的。她在等迈克尔（Michael）签署所有的费用报告，她认为奥斯卡可能拿了她的零食。这让我笑喷了。我们来听听。
Do you think he signed them yet? Signed what? Forget it. Is that chocolate vanilla swirl? Just chocolate. Angela, for the last time, I did not eat your chocolate vanilla swirl. Don't look at me. I don't know why I write my name on things. Chocolate vanilla swirl pudding? Yes.
你觉得他签了吗？签什么？算了。那是巧克力香草旋风吗？只是巧克力。安吉拉，最后一次，我没吃你的巧克力香草旋风。别看着我。我不知道我为什么要在那上面写我的名字。巧克力香草旋风布丁？是的。
Oscar's sitting there and he's just eating the pudding and Angela's just glaring at him. That's my favorite pudding. Is it really? It's either chocolate vanilla swirl or tapioca. Oh, yeah. Well, Angela is positive that he took her pudding. Can you tell maybe I'm a little hangry right now because I'm really zeroing in on what the snack was? Yeah, I just thought that was so cute. I love that Oscar said, for the last time. Like, how many times has she brought it up?
奥斯卡坐在那里，他只是在吃布丁，而安吉拉只是怒视着他。那是我的最爱布丁。真的吗？要么是巧克力香草旋风，要么是木薯。哦，是的。嗯，安吉拉确信他拿了她的布丁。你能看出我可能现在有点“饿怒”吗？因为我真的在纠结那个零食到底是什么？是的，我只是觉得那太可爱了。我喜欢奥斯卡说“最后一次”。就像，她提过多少次了？
Exactly. Okay. Lastly, there were a series of candy bag talking heads. It's everyone reacting to having to stay late. I wanted to share three of them. First of all, Angela says, Michael forces department heads to stay until all the forms are signed. It's not so much a problem for me as it is for my cats. Cats are creatures of habit and they expect mommy home at 6 p.m. sharp. It just makes me laugh that they all call her mommy in her mind. Yes. Well, what do your pets call you? Not mommy. I don't know. I've never thought about it.
正是如此。好的。最后，有一系列关于糖果袋的“谈话头”（talking heads）。每个人都对不得不加班做出反应。我想分享其中的三个。首先，安吉拉说，迈克尔强迫部门主管留下来直到所有表格都签完。这对我的猫来说比对我来说更是个问题。猫是习惯性动物，它们期待妈妈在下午6点准时回家。这让我发笑，因为在她的脑海里，他们都叫她妈妈。是的。嗯，你的宠物叫你什么？不是妈妈。我不知道。我从来没想过。
Well. What? Oh, my gosh. Clearly your pets have a name for you. Yeah. What? Motho. Oh, good Lord. What? Motho?
嗯。什么？天哪。显然你的宠物对你有称呼。是的。什么？Motho。哦，天哪。什么？Motho？
Yeah. Oh my gosh, Jenna. Hi, Motho. Oh my gosh. That is hilarious. I've never even thought about it. Wait, Cassie, you have cats. Do they have a name for you?
是的。天哪，珍娜。嗨，Motho。天哪。那太搞笑了。我甚至从来没想过。等等，凯西（Cassie），你有猫。它们有对你的称呼吗？
They just call me Mama. Oh my gosh. See? Mama and Motho. Sam, does Ramin call you something? They just call me mama. Oh my gosh! Mama and mother. Does Robin call you something? No, no, no. He's indifferent to me at best. I see. I've never thought of it. I'm going to ask my kids. What do they think?
它们只是叫我妈妈（Mama）。天哪。你看？Mama和Motho。萨姆（Sam），拉明（Ramin）叫你什么吗？它们只是叫我妈妈。天哪！Mama和Mother。罗宾（Robin）叫你什么吗？不，不，不。他对我顶多是冷漠。我明白了。我从来没想过。我要问问我的孩子们。他们是怎么想的？
Call me. I'll report back. All right. The next talking head is Toby. He says, when I stay past five, I start counting the holes in the ceiling. Last year, I got to 457. Whomp, whomp, whomp. Sad Sack Toby.
给我打电话。我会回来汇报的。好的。下一个“谈话头”是托比（Toby）。他说，当我待到五点以后，我就开始数天花板上的洞。去年，我数到了457个。咚，咚，咚。悲伤的托比。
And the last one is a talking head from Stanley. Tonight is Bridge Night. I hate canceling Bridge Night. That's so tracks that he plays Bridge. I love it. I do too. I actually love this detail. Well those are my second drink tidbits for this episode. Join us this Wednesday for All
最后一个是斯坦利（Stanley）的“谈话头”。今晚是桥牌之夜。我讨厌取消桥牌之夜。他打桥牌这一点太符合他的人设了。我喜欢。我也喜欢。我其实很喜欢这个细节。好了，这就是我这一集的“第二杯”花絮。本周三加入我们，一起
About Kevin Malone with special guest Brian Baumgartner. See you then. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. We are just rocking out to our own intro. We were actually dancing and miming the words.
聊聊凯文·马龙（Kevin Malone），特别嘉宾是布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）。到时候见。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。我们只是在跟着自己的开场白摇摆。我们实际上是在跳舞和模仿歌词。
Hello everyone. Today we are going to be talking about The Fight. The Fight. Season two, episode six, written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, known to us as Gene and Lee. They're a duo. They're funny fellas. This episode was directed by Ken Quapus.
大家好。今天我们要谈论的是《打架》。《打架》。第二季第六集，由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基（Gene Stupnitsky）和李·艾森伯格（Lee Eisenberg）编剧，我们称他们为吉恩和李。他们是一对搭档。他们是风趣的家伙。这一集由肯·夸普斯（Ken Kwapis）执导。
We love Ken Quapus. We love Ken Quapus. We love Ken Quapus. I don't even know if it's possible for people to understand our love of Ken Quapus. I don't know guys. There are some directors that just are in our hearts. Ken Quapus, Paul Feig, Charles McDougall. Charles McDougall. For yelling action at us.
我们爱肯·夸普斯。我们爱肯·夸普斯。我们爱肯·夸普斯。我甚至不知道人们是否能理解我们对肯·夸普斯的爱。我不知道，伙计们。有些导演就是住在我们的心里。肯·夸普斯，保罗·费格（Paul Feig），查尔斯·麦克杜格尔（Charles McDougall）。查尔斯·麦克杜格尔。因为对我们大喊“开始”。
For a different way though. Yeah. Like Ken Quapus is like a cozy blanket. Paul Feig you want to hang out with all day. And drink martinis. Mm-hmm. Charles McDougall you kind of want to get drunk in a pub with and yell at people. It's so true.
不过是以不同的方式。是的。肯·夸普斯就像一条舒适的毯子。保罗·费格是你整天都想和他待在一起的人。喝马提尼。嗯。查尔斯·麦克杜格尔是你有点想在酒吧里喝醉并对人大喊大叫的人。太真实了。
We'll talk about Charles McDougall when we get to him. We haven't really had a chance to talk about him, but that was a little preview. We have a special treat today. Our summary of this episode is going to be read by a fan. So here we go. Alexis is describing the fight. Dwight becomes assistant to the sensei at his dojo and spends the day bragging and telling everyone how tough he is. Michael has a lot of papers to sign. Jim and Pam use the opportunity to trick Michael by saying they think Dwight is stronger than Michael is. So Michael agrees to duel Dwight at the dojo
当我们谈到查尔斯·麦克杜格尔时，我们会聊到他。我们还没有真正有机会谈论他，但这只是一个小预告。我们今天有一个特别的款待。我们这一集的摘要将由一位粉丝朗读。所以我们开始吧。亚历克西斯正在描述《打架》。德怀特成为了他道场的教练助理，并花了一整天时间吹嘘并告诉每个人他有多强硬。迈克尔有很多文件要签。吉姆（Jim）和帕姆（Pam）利用这个机会戏弄迈克尔，说他们认为德怀特比迈克尔强。所以迈克尔同意在道场与德怀特决斗
to prove his manliness and procrastinate doing his work. I thought that was very good. That was really good. I feel like she covered it. She was very concise. I feel like maybe she wrote it down and read it, which is what I would do. So Alexis, I'm with you. Alexis, you've made a friend.
以证明他的男子气概并拖延他的工作。我觉得那非常好。那真的很好。我觉得她涵盖了重点。她非常简洁。我觉得也许她写下来并读了出来，这正是我会做的。所以亚历克西斯，我和你站在一起。亚历克西斯，你交到了一个朋友。
That's right. All right, let's get into the fast facts for the fight. Fast fact number one, this is the first episode from our new writing team of Jean and Lee. I emailed with Lee, Eisenberg, okay? And he told me that before getting hired on the office, Jean was a part-time nanny and Lee was an assistant to a director. This was their first staff writing job. They were over the moon and they were particularly excited about the free lunches. I can really relate to that.
没错。好了，让我们进入《打架》的速览。速览第一条，这是我们新的编剧团队吉恩和李的第一集。我和李·艾森伯格通过邮件交流过，好吗？他告诉我，在被《办公室》聘用之前，吉恩是一名兼职保姆，而李是一名导演助理。这是他们的第一份专职编剧工作。他们欣喜若狂，尤其是对免费午餐感到兴奋。我真的很有共鸣。
I can too. When I interned on Conan O'Brien, I got free food and I was so excited. Every time I got a job as an actor, when I was a struggling actor, I got excited about the free meals, the free food at work. It's a big deal. I kind of still get excited about it. I have to be honest. I mean, I hate to break it to everyone at earwolf, but I hit up that fruit bowl hard every morning when we come here. Yeah, like apple, banana. earwolf has a basket of chips. That really good, too. When I worked in offices in real life, I used to get really excited to go in the break room
我也一样。当我在柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）那里实习时，我有免费食物，我非常兴奋。每次我作为演员得到一份工作，当我还是个挣扎的演员时，我对免费餐点、工作时的免费食物感到兴奋。这很重要。我到现在还是会为此感到兴奋。我必须诚实地说。我的意思是，我不想打破耳狼（Earwolf）所有人的幻想，但我们每天早上来这里时，我都会猛吃那个水果碗。是的，比如苹果、香蕉。耳狼有一篮薯片。那个也很好。当我在现实生活中的办公室工作时，我过去常常很兴奋地去休息室，
and someone would bring in some Danish or some muffins or cookies. I don't know. If you were anything like me, I would eat ramen noodles because you could buy nine for $1. Oh, yeah. Oh, man. You know, ramen noodles are really
有人会带一些丹麦酥、松饼或饼干来。我不知道。如果你像我一样，我会吃拉面，因为你可以用1美元买9包。哦，是的。哦，天哪。你知道，拉面对于有孩子的家庭餐来说真的是
a great meal for family meals with kids. You can spruce it up. You can saute some brown chicken and put a bunch of veggies in with the noodles. You can also not cook them at all and crunch them up and put them in a salad instead of a crouton. This has turned into a different show. Okay. That's like a, you can make a Chinese chicken salad. You can use ramen noodles as your crunchies. Wow. There you go. Some more information from Lee about this being his first episode.
一顿很棒的饭。你可以把它装饰一下。你可以炒一些棕色鸡肉，在面条里放一堆蔬菜。你也可以根本不煮它们，把它们压碎，放在沙拉里代替面包丁。这变成了一个不同的节目。好的。那就像一个，你可以做一个中式鸡肉沙拉。你可以用拉面作为你的脆片。哇。给你。关于这是他第一集的一些来自李的信息。
He said they were terrified because remember we talked about how they break down the episodes as a group and then writers get assigned to write the episode. He said that since their episode was episode six, they had very little in their outline. He said they had fleshed out the other episodes much more than this one. And he thought that they were being set up to fail. They were being tested. Yes, exactly. Because he was like, how do you give the staff writers with the least amount of experience, the least worked on outline? Yes, exactly.
他说他们很害怕，因为记得我们谈过他们是如何分组解析剧集的，然后编剧被分配去写剧集。他说因为他们的剧集是第六集，他们在提纲里几乎没什么内容。他说他们把其他剧集的内容比这一集充实得多。他认为他们被设定为失败。他们正在接受测试。是的，正是如此。因为他当时想，你怎么能给经验最少的专职编剧最少工作的提纲呢？是的，正是如此。
He said after they turned in their script and they had to get their notes on their script, Greg had pneumonia and they had to go to Greg's house in order to get their notes. And he said the thing that really stood out to him was that he explained the idea of the Jim Pam subtext to Jean and Lee. They had written a really on-the-nose Jim Pam scene, and Greg said, sometimes just a look is enough. And he said it kind of blew their minds, and that Greg completely brought that idea to them. And in the episode, something I remember is when Pam is reading Jim's palm, that was a big deal. It was how there was always this discussion, how can Jim and
他说在他们交了剧本并不得不得到剧本反馈后，格雷格（Greg）得了肺炎，他们不得不去格雷格家才能得到反馈。他说真正让他印象深刻的是，他向吉恩和李解释了吉姆和帕姆潜台词的想法。他们写了一个非常直白的吉姆和帕姆的场景，格雷格说，有时候一个眼神就足够了。他说这让他们大开眼界，格雷格完全把那个想法带给了他们。在这一集中，我记得的一件事是当帕姆在看吉姆的手相时，那是一件大事。一直有这样的讨论，吉姆和
Pam physically touch without it being inappropriate? Right. Well, lady, I think that was very intimate. I even looked up online about hand touching, and it is considered physical intimacy. That was some major flirting. That's a note card I have for later. All right. Should we move on to fast fact number two? Let's do it.
帕姆如何在不显得不恰当的情况下进行身体接触？对。嗯，女士，我认为那非常亲密。我甚至在网上查了关于手部接触的信息，它被认为是身体亲密。那是非常严重的调情。那是我稍后要用的笔记卡。好了。我们应该进入速览第二条吗？我们开始吧。
All right, fast fact number two, Sensei Ira was played by Lance Krall. Is it Sansei or Sensei? Oh my gosh. Sensei Ira was played by Lance Krall who's a friend of mine and I have five note cards on him because he and I talked on the phone yesterday. You know that I was very starstruck by him when he was on our episode. I know. He even said, I think Jenna watched a lot of Joe Schmo.
好的，速览第二条，伊拉教练由兰斯·克拉尔饰演。是Sansei还是Sensei？天哪。伊拉教练由兰斯·克拉尔饰演，他是我的朋友，我有五张关于他的笔记卡，因为我和他昨天通了电话。你知道当他在我们那一集时，我对他非常着迷。我知道。他甚至说，我想珍娜看了很多《乔·施莫秀》。
Yes, that cracks me up that he said that. Because I did corner him at lunch one day, and I made him tell me everything about the Joe Schmo show. If you guys have not seen this, please go look it up. The Joe Schmo show was a fake reality show contest where everybody on the show were actors, except for one person. The Joe Schmo guy was a real person. And everyone around him was acting
是的，他说那话让我笑喷了。因为我确实有一天在午餐时把他堵住了，我让他告诉我关于《乔·施莫秀》的一切。如果你们还没看过这个，请去查一下。《乔·施莫秀》是一个虚假的真人秀竞赛，节目里的每个人都是演员，除了一个人。乔·施莫那个人是一个真实的人。而他周围的每个人都在表演，
like they were in a reality show. Yes, and they were locked in this house. And they had to do competitions and vote each other off at the end. By the way, Kristen Wiig is on that show with Lance. A lot of great comedians and improvisers that I knew were on that show. I auditioned for that.
好像他们在一个真人秀节目里。是的，他们被锁在这个房子里。他们必须进行比赛，并在最后投票淘汰对方。顺便说一句，克里斯汀·韦格（Kristen Wiig）和兰斯一起参加了那个节目。我认识的很多伟大的喜剧演员和即兴表演者都参加了那个节目。我为那个试镜过。
It was cast by Alison Jones and I was devastated when I did not get it because I thought what an amazing acting experience to like live in a house and have to play this character 24 seven. And by the way, the show is brilliant. So yes, I am starstruck by Lance. I can't believe you know him. I can't believe I didn't know that you know him. So I emailed him yesterday and I was like, Lance, we're going to be talking about the
它是艾莉森·琼斯选角的，当我没得到它时，我非常沮丧，因为我想，住在一个房子里并不得不24小时全天候扮演这个角色，那将是多么棒的表演体验。顺便说一句，这个节目很精彩。所以是的，我被兰斯迷住了。我不敢相信你认识他。我不敢相信我不知道你认识他。所以我昨天给他发了邮件，我说，兰斯，我们要谈论
fight. Where are you? Can you hop on the phone? And he was like, I'm actually in Atlanta. He has moved to Atlanta and he set up his own production company because he's really talented. He's an actor, comedian, writer. And he has a production company in Atlanta called Picture It Productions.
《打架》了。你在哪？你能打个电话吗？他说，我其实在亚特兰大。他搬到了亚特兰大，并成立了自己的制作公司，因为他真的很有才华。他是一名演员、喜剧演员、作家。他在亚特兰大有一家制作公司，叫“想象它制作公司”（Picture It Productions）。
How about that? You can check it out at PictureItProductions.com. All right, Lance. So we met so long ago and I said, Lance, did we meet doing improv? I can't remember exactly how we met. And he remembered exactly and it made me laugh so hard. What?
怎么样？你可以在PictureItProductions.com上查看。好了，兰斯。所以我们很久以前就认识了，我说，兰斯，我们是在做即兴表演时认识的吗？我不记得我们是怎么认识的了。他记得一清二楚，这让我笑得好厉害。什么？
Okay. So he was friends. We had mutual friends and I went into an editing bay where a friend of ours worked and they were helping me with my acting reel. Okay. And I said, Lance, was this before the office? He said, no, Angela, it was like after the pilot but you really didn't think the show was gonna go.
好的。所以他是朋友。我们有共同的朋友，我走进了一个我们朋友工作的剪辑室，他们正在帮我制作我的表演作品集（acting reel）。好的。我说，兰斯，这是在《办公室》之前吗？他说，不，安吉拉，那是在试播集之后，但你真的没觉得这个节目会火。
So you were trying to put some of your office like scene with Kevin and accounting in your reel. Should we say what a reel is? Yes, yes. So just for people who don't know, like, you know, actors have a headshot and on the back is their resume and you give that at auditions, but you also would send a link to clips of various performances you had been on and that's your acting reel. It helps you get jobs.
所以你试图把你的一些像在会计部和凯文在一起的《办公室》场景放进你的作品集里。我们应该说说什么是作品集吗？是的，是的。所以对于不知道的人来说，你知道，演员有头像，背面是简历，你在试镜时会给这个，但你也会发送一个链接，里面有你参与过的各种表演的片段，那就是你的表演作品集。它能帮你找到工作。
So if you were putting together your acting reel with some clips from the office. Right, and this clips, and this really dates me and our show because it was all on VHS. Oh my gosh. There was a guy actually editing it. Yes, and I had brought in like a box of all of my footage and they were putting together a montage of my scenes.
所以如果你正在用《办公室》的一些片段制作你的表演作品集。对，这些片段，这真的让我和我们的节目显得很老，因为那都是在VHS录像带上的。天哪。当时真的有一个人在剪辑它。是的，我带了一箱我所有的素材，他们正在把我的场景剪辑成蒙太奇。
And Lance said, Angela, it was so cute and charming because you turned to me and you said, Hey, will you watch this? What do you think of my reel? And he said, and it was every second you've ever been on screen. He said it was so long. And also in some of it, you didn't even have dialogue. You just walked by. That is hilarious. There was like a commercial like I did for Chry dialogue. You just walked by. That is hilarious. There was like a commercial like I did for Chrysler where I walked by and I just went
兰斯说，安吉拉，那太可爱太迷人了，因为你转向我，你说，嘿，你能看这个吗？你觉得我的作品集怎么样？他说，那是你出现在屏幕上的每一秒。他说那太长了。而且在其中一些片段里，你甚至没有对话。你只是走过去。那太搞笑了。有一个像我为克莱斯勒（Chrysler）拍的广告，我走过去，我只是
and I did like did thumbs up at someone. I was like, oh my gosh, Lance, it's so embarrassing. But that's the first time we met. So it was after the pilot when I thought the office wasn't going to go and I was trying to figure out how to get more work. That's very funny that then he ends up being on the show. I know and then he told me he said, Ange, did you know I tested for the role of Jim? He tested for Jim.
我对着某人竖起了大拇指。我说，天哪，兰斯，太尴尬了。但那是我们第一次见面。所以那是在试播集之后，当时我以为《办公室》不会火，我正试图弄清楚如何获得更多工作。他最后竟然出现在节目里，这太搞笑了。我知道，然后他告诉我，他说，安吉拉，你知道我试镜过吉姆的角色吗？他试镜过吉姆。
What? So I must have done scenes with him. He said you weren't in his group on his test day. He had a different group and Bob Odenkirk was in his group for Michael Scott. Oh yes, that's right. I was in the Steve Carell test group. Well, you know something that's funny about Bob Odenkirk since you brought him up. I knew Bob Odenkirk when I was auditioning for the office and we were both called. I was called to do Pam and he was called to do Michael. So we got together and we practiced together.
什么？所以我一定和他演过对手戏。他说你在他试镜那天不在他的小组里。他有另一个小组，鲍勃·奥登科克（Bob Odenkirk）在他的小组里试镜迈克尔·斯科特。哦，是的，没错。我在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）的试镜小组里。嗯，你知道关于鲍勃·奥登科克的一件有趣的事，既然你提到了他。我在为《办公室》试镜时就认识鲍勃·奥登科克，我们都被叫去了。我被叫去演帕姆，他被叫去演迈克尔。所以我们聚在一起，一起练习。
Aww. But then I wasn't in his test group and I had thought, darn it, we worked a bunch of bits together. We were so excited to show them off. But he did this very funny audition where he brought in his guitar and he sang a song to Pam and we had worked it all out. We were going to ask if we could do it if we were paired together, but we never were. So Lance told me this great story that the day that he was screen testing, he's in the lobby waiting. They were all kind of giddy that Bob Odenkirk
噢。但后来我不在他的试镜小组里，我当时想，该死，我们一起排练了很多段子。我们很兴奋能展示它们。但他做了一个非常有趣的试镜，他带了他的吉他，给帕姆唱了一首歌，我们都排练好了。我们本来想问如果我们被配对在一起能不能表演，但我们从来没有。所以兰斯告诉我这个很棒的故事，在他进行屏幕测试的那天，他在大厅等着。他们都因为鲍勃·奥登科克
was in their group. They were all really big fans of Bob's. And Bob walked over to Lance and was like, hey, you want to run lines with me? And Lance was like, uh, sure. And he said it was really cool. And they sort of went out in this lobby and ran lines three or four times,
在他们小组里而有点头晕目眩。他们都是鲍勃的超级粉丝。鲍勃走到兰斯身边说，嘿，你想和我对台词吗？兰斯说，呃，当然。他说那真的很酷。他们在大厅里走了出来，把台词对了三四遍，
like the scenes all the way through. He just thought it was a really cool moment. So Lance said when he read for Jim, he was like, you know, I really felt like I just tried too hard. And he said then when he got called back when we were once the show was up and going for the fight, he read that it was like a martial arts guy and he goes, Oh my gosh, Lance's background is actually martial arts. He was in the martial arts community for 15 years. He has a third degree black belt in taekwondo. He was the sixth in the nation in his like weight category in 1992. He trained junior Olympic gold medalist like he was. Did they know this about him? I mean, I think they didn't.
就像把场景从头到尾演了一遍。他只是觉得那是一个非常酷的时刻。所以兰斯说当他为吉姆试镜时，他说，你知道，我真的觉得我只是太用力了。他说然后当我们在《打架》这一集节目开始后，他被叫回来时，他读到这是一个武术家角色，他说，天哪，兰斯的背景其实是武术。他在武术界待了15年。他有跆拳道三段黑带。他在1992年的体重级别中排名全国第六。他训练过少年奥林匹克金牌得主，就像他那样。他们知道他这一点吗？我的意思是，我想他们不知道。
I don't know. But he said when he saw who the character was, he was like, Oh my gosh, he said, I am not going to try to go for the joke at all. I'm just going to go in as if I'm like working with one of my students and teaching a class. And that's what he did. He put no pizzazz on it. He went in and played it really straight and they loved it. They always loved that. Those are the people they always cast were the people who played it real.
我不知道。但他说当他看到角色是谁时，他说，天哪，他说，我根本不会试图去搞笑。我只是会像和我的学生一起工作并教课一样进去。他就是这么做的。他没有加任何花哨的东西。他进去后演得非常正经，他们很喜欢。他们总是喜欢那样。他们总是选那些演得真实的人。
This leads me to my third fast fact, Angela. I know you might have more to say about Lance. No, no, no, go, go. But this is a fan question. Is anyone on the cast trained in martial arts? That's from Will. So yes, Lance and also Rainn Wilson studied karate his sophomore year in college and is a yellow belt.
这引出了我的第三个速览，安吉拉。我知道你可能还有更多关于兰斯的话要说。不，不，不，去吧，去吧。但这是一个粉丝问题。演员阵容里有人受过武术训练吗？那是威尔（Will）问的。所以是的，兰斯，还有雷恩·威尔森（Rainn Wilson）在大学二年级时学习过空手道，是黄带。
I didn't know that. Yes, and I asked Rain if the writers knew that and he said no. Isn't that what a weird coincidence that they wrote this whole karate themed episode and Rain is a yellow belt and Lance was a black belt. Yes, that is so wild. Okay.
我不知道。是的，我问雷恩编剧是否知道这一点，他说不知道。这难道不是一个奇怪的巧合吗？他们写了这一整集空手道主题的剧集，而雷恩是黄带，兰斯是黑带。是的，那太疯狂了。好的。
Do you have more Lance stuff? Cause I interrupted your Lance cards with my fast facts. He actually had a really funny thing that made me laugh. He said that when they got to the actual fight and the choreography of the fight, he said he was so surprised because there was no choreography. There was no stunt guy. He said literally it was like, OK, guys, just two idiots
你还有更多兰斯的东西吗？因为我用我的速览打断了你的兰斯笔记卡。他其实有一件非常有趣的事情让我笑喷了。他说当他们进行实际的打架和打架编排时，他说他非常惊讶，因为根本没有编排。没有特技演员。他说字面上就像是，好吧，伙计们，只是两个白痴
try to hit each other. This was very early on. We did not have a budget. That's what I told him budget for these kinds of things. I told him. I said, Lance, this does not surprise me, because they put Phil Shea, our prop guy, in a box for hours. There was no stunt person.
试着打对方。这非常早。我们没有预算。这就是我告诉他的，这些事情的预算。我告诉他。我说，兰斯，这并不让我惊讶，因为他们把我们的道具师菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）关在盒子里好几个小时。没有特技演员。
In the early years of The Office, I always felt like it was a show we were making in our garage for our neighborhood. I always felt like it was a one act play we were doing in someone's garage. As a kid, I used to do that. I used to put on plays in my garage and the garage door was the curtain.
在《办公室》的早期，我总觉得这是一个我们在车库里为邻居制作的节目。我总觉得这是一个我们在某人的车库里演的独幕剧。小时候，我过去常那样做。我过去常在车库里演戏，车库门就是幕布。
Yeah. And so, and I would like put chairs out on my driveway for the neighborhood kids to come see my show. It was like a puppet show or a variety show. That's what the office always felt like to me. Just like a bunch of us making a show in our garage. Yeah. So this won't be the last time you see Sensei Ira.
是的。而且我会把椅子放在车道上，让邻居的孩子们来看我的表演。那就像一个木偶戏或综艺节目。这就是《办公室》一直给我的感觉。就像我们一群人在车库里制作一个节目。是的。所以这不会是你最后一次看到伊拉教练。
He does come back in season nine in the episode Junior Salesman. He does? Yes. What does he do in that episode? He was actually there to interview for a job. Oh, I remember that. Oh, Dwight brings in a bunch of his old friends and weirdos to interview.
他确实在第九季的《初级推销员》那一集中回来了。他回来了？是的。他在那一集里做什么？他其实是去面试工作的。哦，我记得那个。哦，德怀特带了一堆他的老朋友和怪人来面试。
And like family members. Yes. Lance emailed me a great behind the scenes photo of him and the other people interviewing for jobs in the conference room. And he has his karate outfit on over a business suit. So his tie is like poking out. It's like so odd. But yeah, he was on season one and then on season nine.
还有家庭成员。是的。兰斯给我发了一张很棒的幕后照片，是他和其他人在会议室面试工作。他穿着空手道服，外面套着西装。所以他的领带像戳出来一样。太奇怪了。但是的，他出现在第一季，然后是第九季。
So he sort of had this great perspective of being on the bookends of the show. What a very, very cool thing. Yeah. Thank you so much, Lance, for taking time out of your schedule in Atlanta to chat me up. And we're going to call you again, come Junior Salesman. Yeah, I love it.
所以他算是对这部剧的开头和结尾都有了很棒的视角。多么非常非常酷的事情。是的。非常感谢兰斯，从你在亚特兰大的日程中抽出时间来和我聊天。我们还会再给你打电话的，等《初级推销员》的时候。是的，我喜欢。
All right, let's take a break and we'll be back to break down the fight. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. break down the fight. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Every January is a time when I feel like we all reflect. You know, you can really do it any time of the year, but I think, you know, you do feel that reset. You do.
好了，让我们休息一下，回来解析《打架》。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。解析《打架》。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。每年的每一月都是我觉得我们都在反思的时候。你知道，你真的可以在一年中的任何时候做，但我认为，你知道，你确实会感觉到那种重置。你会的。
It's like you have 365 blank pages ahead of you just waiting to be filled and you can decide how to do that I'm so poetic Angela. Oh really? Thanks. 365 blank pages. Well, I might have had some help. All right. Well, I'm going with your book metaphor Okay, you could think of therapy as your editorial partner Helping you to write these new chapters and create the meaningful story that you deserve to live. How do you like that? I really like it a lot. BetterHelp is fully online and making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. It has a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. And you can switch therapists at any time at no extra cost.
就像你有365个空白页面在你面前等着被填满，你可以决定如何做。我太有诗意了，安吉拉。哦，真的吗？谢谢。365个空白页面。嗯，我可能得到了一些帮助。好的，我要用你的书的隐喻。好的，你可以把治疗看作是你的编辑伙伴，帮助你写这些新的篇章，并创造你值得拥有的有意义的故事。你觉得怎么样？我真的很喜欢。BetterHelp完全在线，让治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。它拥有一个由超过30,000名拥有广泛专业领域的认证治疗师组成的多元化网络。而且你可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。
Write your story with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. Calling all sellers. Salesforce is hiring account executives to join us on the or call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com.
用BetterHelp写下你的故事。今天访问betterhelp.com/office ladies，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp.com/office ladies。呼叫所有销售人员。Salesforce正在招聘客户主管加入我们，或者致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。
Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com. Or you can call us at salesforce.com.first future together. Head to salesforce.com slash careers to learn more. What's up, Spotify? This is Javi. I remember this one time we were on tour. We didn't have any guitar picks and we didn't have time to go to the store, so we placed an order on
或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。或者你可以致电salesforce.com。共同开启未来。前往salesforce.com/careers了解更多。怎么了，Spotify？我是哈维（Javi）。我记得有一次我们在巡演。我们没有任何吉他拨片，也没有时间去商店，所以我们在
Prime and it got there the next day, ready for the show. Whatever you're into, it's on Prime. And we are back. Hello. This episode begins with a prank. Jim pranks Dwight by putting his desk in the bathroom. Poor Dwight. This was a good one. This was a good prank.
Prime上下了订单，第二天就到了，准备好演出。无论你喜欢什么，Prime上都有。我们回来了。你好。这一集以一个恶作剧开始。吉姆通过把德怀特的桌子放在浴室里来戏弄他。可怜的德怀特。这是一个好戏。这是一个好恶作剧。
I like this one. You have to look for Kevin in the background at the end when he leaves one of the stalls. He has a lit candle and a newspaper. And for all of you office geeks, this was the moment that led to Kevin's line in Office Olympics about the bathroom candle smelling like cookies. Also, remember that in the Dundee's, he did win the Don't Go In There After Me award. Yes. And I Yes We see why also though guys Who is lighting candles inside the stall?
我喜欢这个。你必须在最后凯文离开其中一个隔间时留意背景里的他。他拿着一支点燃的蜡烛和一份报纸。对于所有《办公室》极客来说，这就是导致凯文在《办公室奥运会》（Office Olympics）中说浴室蜡烛闻起来像饼干那句台词的时刻。另外，记住在《邓迪奖》（The Dundies）中，他确实赢得了“别在我之后进去”奖。是的。而且我是的，我们看到了原因，伙计们。谁在隔间里点蜡烛？
Like he doesn't come out and light the candle he exits the stall holding a candle a lit candle Yes, and that candle really did smell like cookies. I want to say that did you notice that there is another door by the urinal? Angela where does it go? We don't know. I like to think maybe- What is that door? Is it a utility closet? That's what I think. I think there's like a mop in there or something. That's my guess. Yeah. Those bathrooms did not work. It was very deceiving. We would have people come visit us on the set like guests, family members, and they would go in there thinking that they were real bathrooms and they weren't. In the next scene, Dwight calls his sensei. Jim asks if he's talking to his mother. I
就像他不是出来点蜡烛的，他拿着一支蜡烛，一支点燃的蜡烛离开了隔间。是的，那支蜡烛真的闻起来像饼干。我想说，你注意到小便池旁边还有一扇门吗？安吉拉，它通向哪里？我们不知道。我喜欢想也许——那扇门是什么？它是杂物间吗？这就是我想的。我想里面有拖把之类的东西。这是我的猜测。是的。那些浴室根本不能用。它非常有欺骗性。我们会有客人来片场参观，比如客人、家庭成员，他们会以为那是真正的浴室，但其实不是。在下一个场景中，德怀特给他的教练打电话。吉姆问他是不是在和妈妈说话。我
love that. I think John is really good in that scene. And then there is his whole talking head about being a sensei, assistant to the sensei. What is it? So yeah, Dwight says he's the senpai, which is basically like the assistant to the sensei, assistant to the sensei? What is it? So yeah, Dwight says he's the senpai, which is basically like the assistant to the sensei. Yeah, not assistant sensei. Right. But also actually it's not him. It's like the girl, remember? Because later in the episode, Sensei Ira is like, there's my senpai. So we learned that it's actually not Dwight. Oh my gosh, I missed that. Yeah, the girl that walks through the scene is actually the Senpai. Oh, I totally missed that. All right, so next we have Pam's talking head,
喜欢那个。我觉得约翰（John）在那个场景里演得真好。然后是他关于成为教练、教练助理的整个“谈话头”。是什么？所以是的，德怀特说他是“前辈”（senpai），这基本上就像是教练的助理，教练的助理？是什么？所以是的，德怀特说他是“前辈”，这基本上就像是教练的助理。是的，不是助理教练。对。但其实也不是他。是那个女孩，记得吗？因为在这一集后面，伊拉教练说，那是我的前辈。所以我们了解到其实不是德怀特。天哪，我错过了那个。是的，那个走过场景的女孩其实才是前辈。哦，我完全错过了。好的，接下来我们有帕姆的“谈话头”，
and this is when we find out that today is the day that Michael has to sign time cards, purchase order approvals, and expense reports that they're all due at the end of the day, and this happens a couple times a year, and he always procrastinates wildly on these days. As a former secretary, I really relate to the dynamic between Pam and Michael in this episode. Because during one of my early secretarial jobs, I had a boss that would take so long to do his end of the month
这是我们发现今天就是迈克尔必须签署考勤卡、采购订单审批和费用报告的日子，它们都在今天结束时到期，这种情况一年发生几次，他总是在这些日子里疯狂拖延。作为一名前秘书，我真的对这一集中帕姆和迈克尔之间的动态很有共鸣。因为在我早期的秘书工作之一中，我有一个老板，他做月底报告花的时间太长了，
report that I would have to drive to the airport because the FedEx at the airport had the latest drop time. I'm saying LAX Airport, which anyone who lives in Los Angeles, if I drive to LAX now, it's about a two hour drive. So I would have to drive to the airport for like the 7 p.m. It might've even been 9 p.m. FedEx drop. Also there's nowhere to park. Nowhere to park. And people are blowing whistles at p.m. It might've even been 9 p.m. FedEx drop.
以至于我不得不开车去机场，因为机场的联邦快递（FedEx）有最晚的投递时间。我说的是洛杉矶国际机场（LAX），任何住在洛杉矶的人都知道，如果我现在开车去LAX，大约需要两个小时。所以我不得不开车去机场赶比如晚上7点的。甚至可能是晚上9点的联邦快递投递。而且没地方停车。没地方停车。人们在吹哨子。
Also, there's nowhere to park. Nowhere to park. And people are blowing whistles at you. Yes. Like move out of the way. It's like chaos. I do love that Pam calls it the perfect storm. I do too.
而且没地方停车。没地方停车。人们在吹哨子。是的。就像让开。那就像混乱。我确实喜欢帕姆称之为“完美风暴”。我也喜欢。
Also though, Michael isn't having even to do any work. It's not like he's having to put together a report. All he has to do is sign them. It's so basic. That's right. It's just his signature. It could take him like 20 minutes. Yeah. And he'd be done.
不过，迈克尔甚至不需要做任何工作。他不是必须整理报告。他所要做的只是签署它们。这太基础了。没错。只是他的签名。这可能只需要他20分钟。是的。他就完成了。
This is why I would get so mad at my boss, who couldn't manage to get his report done, because I would think to myself, it's not new information. It's a boilerplate report that you have to do every month. It wasn't a special project that sneaked up on us. Time management, dude. You can see I'm still a little angry about it. Well, if I had to drive to the airport to mail something, I'd be ticked off for a long time. All right. So next up in Michael's attempt to procrastinate, he tells Ryan to update the
这就是为什么我会对我那个无法完成报告的老板感到如此生气，因为我会想，这不是什么新信息。这是一个你每个月都必须做的样板报告。这不是一个突然冒出来的特殊项目。时间管理，伙计。你可以看出我对此仍然有点生气。嗯，如果我不得不开车去机场寄东西，我会很长一段时间都很火大。好了。那么接下来，在迈克尔试图拖延的过程中，他告诉瑞恩（Ryan）去更新
emergency contacts. So I enter that scene where Michael is telling Ryan to do the emergency contacts. So I enter that scene where Michael is telling Ryan to do the emergency contact list. I was so concentrated on not laughing at Steve who was being so funny in that scene. It took everything I had that when BJ would look at me and say the line, updating emergency contacts, I lost it. I started, it became, you know, in the scenes where you can't stop laughing and you have a trigger? Yeah. It was BJ turning to me and very sadly saying, updating emergency contacts. I think I only got through one scene and I did it by not looking at BJ in the eye.
紧急联系人。所以我进入了那个迈克尔告诉瑞恩去更新紧急联系人列表的场景。我当时非常专注于不笑场，因为史蒂夫在那个场景里太搞笑了。我尽了全力，当BJ看着我说那句台词，“更新紧急联系人”时，我崩溃了。我开始，它变成了，你知道，在那些你无法停止大笑并且有触发点的场景里？是的。是BJ转向我，非常悲伤地说，“更新紧急联系人”。我想我只演完了一个场景，我是通过不看BJ的眼睛才做到的。
Like I stared at his forehead. I spent nine years looking at Steve Carell's forehead. Because if I made eye contact with Steve, I used to say he would just like suck out your soul. You made eye contact with him through comedy. I could not lock eyes with him or I would start laughing. So I would, I would look at his forehead. Every conference room scene.
就像我盯着他的额头看。我花了九年时间盯着史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的额头看。因为如果我和史蒂夫有眼神交流，我常说他会把你的灵魂吸走。你通过喜剧和他进行眼神交流。我无法和他对视，否则我会笑场。所以我只能盯着他的额头看。每一场会议室的戏都是这样。
I would have to do that or look at someone's ear. Yes. Or their eyebrows. Yeah, their neck. Yeah, just not in the eyes. Not in the eyes. Well, I thought that was a major PamSass moment. I think you have two really good PamSass moments
我不得不这样做，或者盯着别人的耳朵看。是的。或者他们的眉毛。对，他们的脖子。对，就是不能看眼睛。不能看眼睛。嗯，我觉得那是帕姆非常“毒舌”的时刻。我觉得你在这一集里有两个非常棒的帕姆“毒舌”时刻。
in this episode, and one of them is where you just walk out while he's talking. And he's like, oh, she just left. I'm going to finish talking. I was really channeling my real life experience working for that crazy guy. Michael gets Ryan's phone number in this episode. He's so delighted.
在这一集里，其中一个就是当他在说话时，你直接走开了。他当时说，哦，她就这么走了。我要继续说完。我当时真的在传达我在现实生活中为那个疯子工作的经历。迈克尔在这一集里拿到了瑞安的电话号码。他非常高兴。
He keeps calling him and doing voices. And Angela, flip phone. Flip phone, outdated phone, is very featured in this episode. As is my favorite thing is when Steve as Michael Scott cracks himself up. It's like one of my favorite thing is when Steve is Michael Scott cracks himself up. It's like one of my favorite things. Yes. We talked about this a little bit in the opening, Pam reading Jim's palm. Yeah. I have, that's a note card I'm going to reach for six minutes, 11 seconds, you guys major Pam and Jim a flirt happening. So touching someone's hand is actually like that, like how you were
他不停地给他打电话，还变换着声音。还有安吉拉，翻盖手机。翻盖手机，过时的手机，在这一集中非常抢眼。就像我最喜欢的一点是，当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔·斯科特把自己逗笑的时候。这就像是我最喜欢的事情之一。是的。我们在开场时稍微谈到了这一点，帕姆给吉姆看手相。是的。我有，那是一张我打算在6分11秒提到的笔记卡，你们这些家伙，帕姆和吉姆之间有重大的调情发生。所以触摸别人的手实际上就像那样，就像你当时
tracing his hand, is a sign of physical intimacy. Yeah. Yeah. I know. So that was like, I was like, what is happening? Did you notice on my computer? Yeah, I saw it. I saw that's like your decoy though. That's your way in. Listen, these are two people who shouldn't be flirting, but so desperately want to be flirting. So they have to find ways around it. So listen out there, if you see someone at work who's like trying to read your palm. Oh, they might have a crush on you.
描摹他的手一样，是一种身体亲密的表现。是的。是的。我知道。所以我当时想，这是怎么回事？你注意到我的电脑了吗？是的，我看到了。我看到了，那是你的诱饵。那是你的切入点。听着，这两个人本不该调情，但却非常渴望调情。所以他们必须找到绕过它的方法。所以听着，如果你在工作中看到有人试图给你看手相。哦，他们可能暗恋你。
They might have a crush on you. But I thought it was really cool that the Set Deck people put the palm reading website on my computer. Well, they had to justify why Pam was doing it. Yeah. So here she is board at front reception. She says, Jim, let me read your palm, flirty flirt, sneaky flirt.
他们可能暗恋你。但我认为布景装饰组把看手相的网站放在我的电脑上真的很酷。嗯，他们必须证明帕姆为什么要这么做。是的。所以她当时在前台很无聊。她说，吉姆，让我给你看手相，调情调情，偷偷调情。
I know. I see a note card that you have that is my next topic. Do you want to say it? Well, wait, do you like that this note card only has one word? Yeah. What's that word, Jenna? Stacey. Stacey. Six minutes, 17 seconds. only has one word. Yeah. What's that word, Jenna? Stacy. Stacy.
我知道。我看到你有一张笔记卡是我的下一个话题。你想说吗？等等，你喜欢这张笔记卡只有一个词吗？是的。那个词是什么，珍娜？斯泰西。斯泰西。6分17秒。只有一个词。是的。那个词是什么，珍娜？斯泰西。斯泰西。
Six minutes, 17 seconds. Oh my gosh, Brian, you would crack me up every time you said, Stacy. It's only one word, but it goes through like four octaves. And we used to, that was like, we would, that was a bit. We would tease him. We'd be like, Stacy. At six minutes, we would, that was a bit on the set. We would tease him. We'd be like, Stacey. At six minutes, 49 seconds, there's this whole scene with Jim and Dwight
6分17秒。天哪，布莱恩，你每次说“斯泰西”的时候都会把我逗乐。只有一个词，但它跨越了大约四个八度。我们过去常，那就像是，我们会，那是一个梗。我们会取笑他。我们会说，斯泰西。在6分钟时，我们会，那在片场是一个梗。我们会取笑他。我们会说，斯泰西。在6分49秒，有这一整场吉姆和德怀特的戏
where they're talking and Jim is talking to Dwight about humans versus robots. Yeah. All right, in the background, Phyllis is at her desk. Stanley is not. Where's Stanley? Where is Stanley? Stanley never leaves his desk.
他们正在交谈，吉姆在和德怀特谈论人类与机器人。是的。好吧，在背景中，菲利斯在她的办公桌前。斯坦利不在。斯坦利在哪儿？斯坦利在哪儿？斯坦利从不离开他的办公桌。
He was never missing. Never missing. He's actually one of the characters that is probably the most featured at his desk. We used to joke about this. We would say, why do we all have to be at our desks in the background of all the scenes? Do none of us ever go to the bathroom?
他从不缺席。从不缺席。他实际上是那些在办公桌前出镜率最高的角色之一。我们过去常拿这个开玩笑。我们会说，为什么我们所有人都必须在所有场景的背景中坐在办公桌前？我们中难道没有人去洗手间吗？
Yeah. Do we never leave to go downstairs? Anything. For a reason? Yeah. None of us left our desks, but in particular, Stanley was always at his desk. He had to sit in the background of everyone's talking heads. He was always at his desk. But then you see as they pull back the camera that Stanley is at the file cabinet, but he never filed anything. To me, that was crazy. That's how I knew it was early on in the show because after that, I think Leslie was probably like,
是的。我们从不离开去楼下吗？任何事情。为了一个理由？是的。我们中没有人离开过办公桌，但特别是斯坦利，他总是坐在他的办公桌前。他必须坐在每个人的访谈镜头背景中。他总是坐在他的办公桌前。但当你看到摄像机拉远时，斯坦利在文件柜旁，但他从不归档任何东西。对我来说，这太疯狂了。那就是我知道这是剧集早期的时候，因为在那之后，我想莱斯利大概会说，
yeah, no, I'm not filing. I'm sitting down. I'm sitting down. At seven minutes, 40 seconds, Jenna, it's one of my favorite PamSass moments. What is it? Okay, so Michael has a piece of paper and he's just like practicing his signature.
是的，不，我不归档。我坐着。我坐着。在7分40秒，珍娜，这是我最喜欢的帕姆“毒舌”时刻之一。是什么？好吧，迈克尔有一张纸，他只是在练习他的签名。
Oh yeah. And Pam taps on the glass and goes, you could practice on the forms. I mean, that is some really good Pam sass. Pam is, it's such a great relationship between Pam and Michael because she is his subordinate, yet also his parent. Yes. In many ways. Oh yeah.
哦，是的。帕姆敲了敲玻璃说，你可以在表格上练习。我的意思是，那真的是非常棒的帕姆“毒舌”。帕姆是，帕姆和迈克尔之间的关系太棒了，因为她是他的下属，但也是他的家长。是的。在很多方面。哦，是的。
She has to corral him kind of like a sheep dog might corral the sheep. Okay, at eight minutes, 28 seconds. Oh man, this made me laugh so hard. We learned that Toby's emergency contact is still his ex-wife, even though her new last name is now Becker. And he says, please don't put X. You don't need to put X. You don't need to put X.
她不得不像牧羊犬驱赶羊群一样管束他。好吧，在8分28秒。天哪，这让我笑得太厉害了。我们了解到托比的紧急联系人仍然是他前妻，尽管她现在的新姓氏是贝克。他说，请不要写“前妻”。你不需要写“前妻”。你不需要写“前妻”。
Okay, I have a screen grab I'm going to show you. I took it with my phone. Oh. At nine minutes, 42 seconds, when Jim is saying, you know a ton of 14 year old girls to Michael, there is a brown object in the top left corner. At first I thought, oh, it's a boom. And I froze the frame.
好吧，我有一张截图要给你看。我用手机拍的。哦。在9分42秒，当吉姆对迈克尔说“你认识一堆14岁的小女孩”时，左上角有一个棕色的物体。起初我以为，哦，是个吊杆麦克风。我定格了画面。
I don't know if it's a boom or like an elbow. I don't know what it is. I'm gonna show you a picture of it. All right, she's getting out her phone folks. Okay. All right, tell me what the heck this is. And guys, I want you to look at it, cause it is what?
我不知道那是吊杆麦克风还是像手肘之类的东西。我不知道那是什么。我要给你看一张照片。好吧，伙计们，她拿出手机了。好吧，好吧，告诉我这到底是什么。伙计们，我希望你们看看它，因为它是什么？
We'll put this on officeladies.com. Oh, okay. Now, and then I zoomed in. Do you see it? Yeah. Now look at it close up. What is that? And it's only in that frame.
我们会把它放在officeladies.com上。哦，好的。现在，然后我放大了。你看到了吗？是的。现在近距离看看它。那是什么？而且它只在那一帧里出现。
Is it Michael's shoulder or elbow or something? No, Michael is standing here. See his eyeline? This is here. Michael's right here. I don't know. It's a brown orb, everyone. It's a brown orb and I'm perplexed.
是迈克尔的肩膀还是手肘之类的吗？不，迈克尔站在这里。看他的视线？这是这里。迈克尔就在这儿。我不知道。那是一个棕色的球体，各位。那是一个棕色的球体，我很困惑。
Okay, sorry. We've presented a mystery with no solution. No, that's part of my superpower. I'll notice things, I won't give you answers. We have to talk about what happens at nine minutes, 48 seconds. We have to. What happens? We learned that Michael and Dwight
好吧，抱歉。我们提出了一个没有答案的谜团。不，那是我的超能力的一部分。我会注意到事情，但我不会给你答案。我们必须谈谈9分48秒发生了什么。我们必须谈谈。发生了什么？我们了解到迈克尔和德怀特
spent New Year's Eve together. Yes. And that they watch, oh, they rented, that even dates the show. They rented Armageddon. Yes, and that Dwight cried at the end. Yes. Oh.
一起度过了除夕夜。是的。而且他们看，哦，他们租了，这甚至暴露了剧集的年代。他们租了《世界末日》。是的，而且德怀特在最后哭了。是的。哦。
And I actually- But it was because, why did Dwight cry at the end? It's such brilliant writing. It's because it wasn't just the movie, it was that it began to snow. Yes, it began to snow. At precisely midnight. And it was that it began to snow. Yes, it began to snow. At precisely midnight. And it was like the perfect moment.
而且我实际上——但那是因为，为什么德怀特在最后哭了？这真是精彩的剧本。那是因为不仅仅是电影，而是因为开始下雪了。是的，开始下雪了。在午夜准时。而且那就像是完美的时刻。
I actually saw Armageddon with my dad, because my dad's a drilling engineer. And so he was like, oh, this has drilling engineers in it. And we went and saw it and all throughout the movie. Anytime it was anything drilling related, my dad was like, nope, that's not how you do it, never happened. That's not, nope, not up to code, that never happened. I was like, okay, dad.
我实际上和我爸爸一起看了《世界末日》，因为我爸爸是钻井工程师。所以他当时说，哦，这片子里有钻井工程师。我们去看了，整部电影期间。任何与钻井相关的事情，我爸爸都会说，不，那不是你们的做法，从来没发生过。那不是，不，不符合规范，那从来没发生过。我说，好吧，爸爸。
But I went down the rabbit hole last night, like I do sometimes. I went looking for the Joe Schmo show. I looked up Armageddon last night and I found a few different synopsises of what the movie was about. And it's too good to not read, Jenna. It's so classic. 1998, Michael Bay. Are you ready?
但我昨晚钻进了兔子洞，就像我有时做的那样。我昨晚去搜了《乔·施莫秀》。我搜了《世界末日》，我找到了关于这部电影内容的几个不同的梗概。这太好了，不能不读，珍娜。太经典了。1998年，迈克尔·贝。你准备好了吗？
I'm ready. When an asteroid the size of Texas threatens to collide with Earth in under a month by the way, NASA honcho Dan Truman played by Billy Bob Thornton determines the only way to stop it is to drill its surface and detonate a nuclear bomb inside the asteroid. This leads him to renowned driller, Harry Stamper, played by Bruce Willis, who agrees to helm the dangerous space mission provided he can bring along his own ragtag crew.
我准备好了。当一颗德克萨斯州大小的小行星威胁要在不到一个月的时间内撞击地球时，顺便说一句，由比利·鲍伯·松顿饰演的NASA负责人丹·杜鲁门确定，阻止它的唯一方法是钻入其表面并在小行星内部引爆核弹。这使他找到了由布鲁斯·威利斯饰演的著名钻井工哈里·斯坦珀，他同意领导这项危险的太空任务，前提是他可以带上他自己那群乌合之众。
Among them is Cockshur, AJ, played by Ben Affleck, who Harry thinks isn't good enough for his daughter Liv Tyler until the mission proves otherwise. Wow. I mean, come on. So your dad was Bruce Willis. My dad was Bruce Willis. The driller, the drilling expert. And he felt that everything Bruce Willis' character dad was Bruce Willis. The driller, the drilling expert. Yeah. And he felt that everything Bruce Willis' character had
其中包括由本·阿弗莱克饰演的AJ，哈里认为他配不上他的女儿丽芙·泰勒，直到任务证明了事实并非如此。哇。我的意思是，得了吧。所以你爸爸是布鲁斯·威利斯。我爸爸是布鲁斯·威利斯。钻井工，钻井专家。他觉得布鲁斯·威利斯饰演的角色所说的一切
to say was inaccurate. Yeah, I would say the two movies my dad got really mouthy about were Armageddon and Twister. Twister, the tornado movie? Yeah, because we live in tornado alley. And they were driving up on this tornado. And a truck flies in the air, like a giant semi truck flies in the air, cows are flying in the air.
都是不准确的。是的，我会说我爸爸特别爱挑刺的两部电影是《世界末日》和《龙卷风》。《龙卷风》，那部龙卷风电影？是的，因为我们住在龙卷风走廊。他们开车冲向这个龙卷风。一辆卡车飞到空中，就像一辆巨大的半挂卡车飞到空中，奶牛在空中飞。
And the guy goes, I think it's Bill Paxson goes, we've got some debris. And my dad goes, debris my ass. I don't know. Anyway, we have to discuss the fact that Pam wants French onion chips. I love French onion chips. Gross.
那个人说，我想是比尔·帕克斯顿说，我们有一些碎片。我爸爸说，碎片个鬼。我不知道。总之，我们必须讨论帕姆想要法式洋葱薯片的事实。我喜欢法式洋葱薯片。恶心。
What? I have a question for you. Was that your personal pick or did Pam, was that scripted? I don't know, but I feel like it could have been my personal pick because a lot of times... If you have to eat something, they ask you. They do. They ask you if you have any food allergies. The props person will call you at home and say, we're doing a dinner scene. Is there anything you can't eat?
什么？我有个问题要问你。那是你的个人选择还是帕姆的，那是剧本写的吗？我不知道，但我觉得那可能是我的个人选择，因为很多时候……如果你必须吃什么东西，他们会问你。他们会的。他们会问你是否有任何食物过敏。道具师会给你家里打电话说，我们要拍一场晚餐戏。有什么你不能吃的吗？
Yeah. I feel like Phil Shea would have been like, Jenna, what bag of chips would you want in case you have to open them up and eat them? Yeah. So you said French onion chips. Yeah. This means you wouldn't have been flirting with anyone the rest of the day, because your breath would be disgusting.
是的。我觉得菲尔·谢会说，珍娜，如果你必须打开并吃掉它们，你想要哪种薯片？是的。所以你说了法式洋葱薯片。是的。这意味着你那天剩下的时间里不会和任何人调情，因为你的口气会很恶心。
Well, that's a good point. I didn't really think of that. I also like a barbecue chip. I love a barbecue chip. Can I tell you a little bit of information about the chips? Yeah. OK. They are Hers chips, H-E-R-R-S. And this is a local Pennsylvania
嗯，那是个好观点。我没怎么想过那个。我也喜欢烧烤味薯片。我喜欢烧烤味薯片。我能告诉你一点关于薯片的信息吗？是的。好的。它们是赫尔斯薯片，H-E-R-R-S。这是一家宾夕法尼亚州的本地
company, the Hers chip. I'm flipping my papers because I was going to talk about this later. Maybe you should have written it on a note card. Oh, I see. No, I'm just saying. Look how easy it is for me to see my information. Little bit of Angela sass, everyone.
公司，赫尔斯薯片。我正在翻我的纸，因为我打算稍后再谈这个。也许你应该把它写在笔记卡上。哦，我明白了。不，我只是说说。看我查看我的信息有多容易。安吉拉的一点点“毒舌”，各位。
All right, here it is. I found it. OK. The Hearse chips are also what we put in our vending machine. So you can spy them in there. And I just think it's cool that we used local stuff to fill out the world. And it's kind of a cool story, this story of hers chips. I went down a rabbit hole, Angela. Well, listen, if I just read you the synopsis of Armageddon, you better tell me
好吧，在这儿。我找到了。好的。赫尔斯薯片也是我们放在自动售货机里的东西。所以你可以在里面发现它们。我只是觉得我们用本地的东西来填充这个世界很酷。这是一个很酷的故事，这个赫尔斯薯片的故事。我钻进了一个兔子洞，安吉拉。好吧，听着，如果我刚给你读了《世界末日》的梗概，你最好告诉我
about hers. Guys, James Herr broke with his family's history of chicken farming. And in 1946, he bought a potato chip company. He was only 21 years old and he bought it for $1,750. Yeah. Wow. And now it's a huge successful company and you can even go there and tour it. You would love that. You can tour the facility. You love a factory tour. You know I love a factory tour. Angela, we've been invited to tour the Sass Factory in San Antonio. They said they would send us some shoes. I want them. I know.
关于赫尔斯的事。伙计们，詹姆斯·赫尔打破了他家族养鸡的历史。1946年，他买下了一家薯片公司。他当时只有21岁，他以1750美元买下了它。是的。哇。现在它是一家巨大的成功公司，你甚至可以去那里参观。你会喜欢那个的。你可以参观工厂。你喜欢工厂参观。你知道我喜欢工厂参观。安吉拉，我们被邀请去参观圣安东尼奥的Sass工厂。他们说他们会寄给我们一些鞋子。我想要它们。我知道。
I want some Sass shoes. I'm really excited about that. And then, I mean, listen, if we're talking factory tours, Jenna, I don't even know how to tell you this. You're gonna be so jealous. But next week, I am going to the tough shed factory for your, that's what she said. That's what she said. I'm going to the tough shed factory. I'm so excited. You guys,
我想要一些Sass鞋。我对此感到非常兴奋。然后，我的意思是，听着，如果我们谈论工厂参观，珍娜，我甚至不知道该怎么告诉你。你会非常嫉妒的。但下周，我要去Tough Shed工厂，为了你的，那是她说的。那是她说的。我要去Tough Shed工厂。我太兴奋了。你们这些家伙，
this is a weird thing that happens to us. I went and bought some tile. I needed some tile because I was doing a renovation outside and I went to this tile showroom is called Arto tile in Los Angeles and they geeked out and they recognized me and they gave me a factory tour. This is a really cool perk. Yes. If you like to see how things are made, I love to see how things are made. I loved that show. How it's made. How it's made. It's so good. I know. And so I've gone on quite a few factory tours as a result of my fame on the office. This is my first factory tour.
这是一件发生在我们身上的奇怪事情。我去买了一些瓷砖。我需要一些瓷砖，因为我在外面做装修，我去了洛杉矶一家叫Arto Tile的瓷砖展厅，他们非常兴奋，认出了我，还带我参观了工厂。这是一个非常酷的福利。是的。如果你喜欢看东西是怎么制造的，我喜欢看东西是怎么制造的。我喜欢那个节目。《制造原理》。《制造原理》。太棒了。我知道。所以因为我在《办公室》里的名气，我参加了不少工厂参观。这是我的第一次工厂参观。
Tough Shed's my first one, and I'm very excited, Jenna. All right. I wish I could go with you. So something I have to talk about, Angela, before we go to break, is the scene at Michael and Jim's desk when Michael talks about being in the damn rascals, his street gang. This is the same scene where they talk about Armageddon. But when Dwight punches Michael in the stomach, he does the double punch and Steve gets hit and he's like,
Tough Shed是我的第一次，我非常兴奋，珍娜。好吧。我真希望我能和你一起去。所以在我休息之前，安吉拉，我必须谈谈迈克尔和吉姆办公桌的那场戏，当时迈克尔谈论他在“该死的捣蛋鬼”街头帮派里。这就是他们谈论《世界末日》的那场戏。但当德怀特打迈克尔的肚子时，他做了双重打击，史蒂夫被打中了，他说，
that was John's weak spot. John would laugh so, so hard. And I think that's why in that scene, there is not a single shot of John's face. If you watch it after he punches Michael in the stomach, he, you never see John's face. Yes. Because he couldn't get through that. He couldn't get through that. He loved whenever Steve couldn't get a word out. Yeah.
那是约翰的弱点。约翰会笑得非常非常厉害。我想这就是为什么在那场戏里，没有一个约翰脸部的镜头。如果你在德怀特打迈克尔肚子之后看它，你永远看不到约翰的脸。是的。因为他无法坚持下去。他无法坚持下去。他喜欢史蒂夫说不出话的时候。是的。
Especially in pain. Yeah. He loved whenever Steve couldn't get a word out. Yeah, especially in pain. Like, there's a scene later we'll talk about, but, you know, Kevin sits on Michael's lap when he's Santa. Oh, yes. And Steve let out like a painful moan, and I didn't think John was gonna be able to get back from that. So this reminds me of that bit that Steve did
特别是在痛苦中。是的。他喜欢史蒂夫说不出话的时候。是的，特别是在痛苦中。就像，后面有一场戏我们会谈到，但是，你知道，凯文在迈克尔扮圣诞老人时坐在他腿上。哦，是的。史蒂夫发出了一声痛苦的呻吟，我不认为约翰能从那里面恢复过来。所以这让我想起了史蒂夫在
on the Dana Carvey show, the nauseous waiter. It's one of the funniest things I've ever seen. You guys have to look it up. Steve did it for us one time when we were in the conference room together. And this is John couldn't handle it. I thought John was going to die.
《达纳·卡维秀》上做的那个梗，恶心的服务员。这是我见过的最有趣的事情之一。你们一定要去查一下。史蒂夫有一次我们在会议室里时为我们表演过。约翰简直受不了。我以为约翰要死了。
I thought John was going to die, but we were weeping. You know when you start laughing where all you do is shake and make no noise? Yes. Because Steve would do this thing. So the waiter, he's a waiter, but food makes him nauseous. So he would walk up to a table and have to give the specials of the day. So he'd be like, so ask me, Jenna, what are the specials of the day?
我以为约翰要死了，但我们当时都在流泪。你知道当你开始笑，除了颤抖和不出声什么都做不了的时候吗？是的。因为史蒂夫会做这件事。所以那个服务员，他是个服务员，但食物让他恶心。所以他会走到桌子旁，不得不报出当天的特色菜。所以他会说，所以问我，珍娜，当天的特色菜是什么？
What are the specials of the day? Well we have bruh, bruh, bruh, broccoli, broccoli. He would start to puke as he listed off the specials. Yes, you'd be like, we have a delicious chicken with a cream sauce. Cream sauce. Sorry, cream sauce. It was so hilarious. It's so good.
当天的特色菜是什么？嗯，我们有，呃，呃，呃，西兰花，西兰花。他开始呕吐，因为他列出了特色菜。是的，你会说，我们有美味的奶油酱鸡肉。奶油酱。抱歉，奶油酱。太搞笑了。太棒了。
We are not doing it justice. We are not doing justice to it at all. Oh my gosh. If Steve ever comes on our podcast. Do you think he would do that? Yes. Oh, I need him to do it. I think he would.
我们没有公正地对待它。我们根本没有公正地对待它。天哪。如果史蒂夫来我们的播客。你觉得他会那样做吗？是的。哦，我需要他那样做。我想他会。
Oh, Steve, come on and do Nauseous Waiter for us. Yes. We would, we would, we would do it. Do you think he would do that? Yes. Oh, I need him to do it. Oh, Steve, come on and do Nauseous Waiter for us. Yes. We would make him do that. We loved that. Angela, I think we should go to a break. I think we should.
哦，史蒂夫，来为我们表演“恶心的服务员”吧。是的。我们会，我们会，我们会做的。你觉得他会那样做吗？是的。哦，我需要他那样做。哦，史蒂夫，来为我们表演“恶心的服务员”吧。是的。我们会让他那样做的。我们喜欢那个。安吉拉，我觉得我们应该休息一下。我觉得我们应该。
I would like to go eat some chips, maybe some sour cream and onion chips from the basket. Clearly, you just want to be the gift that keeps on giving in here. Yes. All right. We'll see you in a second. We're so done with New Year, New You.
我想去吃点薯片，也许是篮子里的酸奶油洋葱薯片。显然，你只是想成为这里不断给予的礼物。是的。好吧。我们一会儿见。我们受够了“新年，新你”。
This year, it's more you on Bumble. More of you shamelessly sending playlists, especially that one filled with show tunes. More of you finding Geminis because you know you always like them. More of you dating with intention because you know what you want. And you know what? We love that for you.
今年，在Bumble上做更多的你。更多毫无羞耻地发送播放列表的你，尤其是那个装满音乐剧歌曲的播放列表。更多找到双子座的你，因为你知道你总是喜欢他们。更多带着意图约会的你，因为你知道你想要什么。而且你知道吗？我们喜欢那样的你。
Someone else will too. Be more you this year and find them on Bumble. With TD Direct Investing, you can get live support. So whether you need help buying a partial share from your favorite tech company, opening a TFSA, or learning about investing tools, we're here to help. But keeping your cat off your keyboard? That's up to you.
别人也会喜欢的。今年做更多的你，在Bumble上找到他们。通过TD Direct Investing，你可以获得实时支持。所以无论你需要帮助从你最喜欢的科技公司购买零股，开设TFSA，还是了解投资工具，我们都在这里提供帮助。但让你的猫远离你的键盘？那取决于你。
Reach out to TD Direct Investing today and make your investing steps count. Plus, enjoy 1% cash back. Conditions apply. Offer ends January 31, 2025. Visit td.com slash DI Offer to learn more. We're back from break. Angela? Yes?
今天就联系TD Direct Investing，让你的投资步骤算数。此外，享受1%的现金返还。条件适用。优惠于2025年1月31日结束。访问td.com/DIOffer了解更多。我们休息回来了。安吉拉？是的？
I have a time code. What? Yeah. I actually have three time codes. Jenna, I'm so proud of you. Thank you. I almost wrote them on notecards and brought in three notecards, but I didn't want to infringe on your notecard
我有一个时间码。什么？是的。我实际上有三个时间码。珍娜，我为你感到骄傲。谢谢。我差点把它们写在笔记卡上并带了三张笔记卡，但我不想侵犯你的笔记卡
thing. First of all, I don't own notecards. I encourage you. I love it. Use it. I mean, Jenna, you don't own a list. I hate to break it to you. I might come in someday with a list.
事情。首先，我不拥有笔记卡。我鼓励你。我喜欢它。用吧。我的意思是，珍娜，你不拥有列表。我不想打破你的幻想。我有一天可能会带着一个列表来。
I think that's fantastic. What is your time code? Well, I was very excited. It's 11 minutes, 50 seconds. And it is the scene where Pam and Jim are walking to the kitchen. John is snapping his fingers like he's from West Side Story. And we got tons of questions about these finger snaps,
我觉得那太棒了。你的时间码是什么？嗯，我非常兴奋。是11分50秒。那是帕姆和吉姆走向厨房的那场戏。约翰像来自《西区故事》一样打着响指。我们收到了大量关于这些响指的问题，
which I think is why I felt compelled to write down the time code. The question was, was this scripted or improvised? I remember it as being improvised, and I remember being so tickled by it, because I'm a huge movie musical fan. And I asked Lee Eisenberg, and he thinks it was also improvised.
我想这就是为什么我感到有必要写下时间码的原因。问题是，这是剧本写的还是即兴创作的？我记得它是即兴创作的，我记得被它逗乐了，因为我是电影音乐剧的超级粉丝。我问了李·艾森伯格，他认为这也是即兴创作的。
He does not remember writing that. I think it was improvised, because it's just like John kind of playing around. Because earlier in the show, he had mentioned, oh, like a jet. And Michael, I think thinks he's a jet. He's like, oh, you're a jet? That was the name of your actual gang. Yeah, so I think John is just playing off of that reference.
他不记得写过那个。我认为它是即兴创作的，因为这就像约翰在玩耍。因为在剧集早些时候，他提到过，哦，像一架喷气机。迈克尔，我想认为他是一架喷气机。他说，哦，你是喷气机？那是你实际帮派的名字。是的，所以我认为约翰只是在利用那个参考。
It was so fun. So then they go into the kitchen. And I have to say, this scene in the kitchen between Michael and Dwight when they face off might be one of my favorite scenes from the entire second season of The Office. In the kitchen, John and I almost started laughing about a million times.
太有趣了。然后他们走进厨房。我必须说，迈克尔和德怀特在厨房里对峙的这场戏可能是《办公室》第二季中我最喜欢的场景之一。在厨房里，约翰和我差点笑了一百万次。
And if you notice, if you look at Mindy, she is constantly turning her back to the scene and looking into the annex. I could see you and John almost break. When I watched this knowing you guys, I was like, oh, they were about to lose it. But seriously watch Mindy through this because she can she cannot face the scene. It's amazing. Well, when when rain like grabs her and it's like, right now from behind, she's like, wait, what? It amazing. I don't know how she got through that. And there's all
如果你注意的话，如果你看明迪，她一直在背对着场景，看着附楼。我能看到你和约翰差点笑场。当我看着这个了解你们时，我想，哦，他们快要失控了。但认真地看着明迪，因为她无法面对这个场景。太神奇了。嗯，当瑞恩抓住她时，就像，从后面，她说，等等，什么？太神奇了。我不知道她是怎么坚持下来的。而且这里面有所有
these great things in this. This is the misuse of common phrases like catch 22. Tit for tit. That's your favorite. My favorite. This is the second time he has said it. Tit for tit. Also, two hits, me punching you and you hitting the floor. So good.
这些伟大的东西。这是对常用短语的误用，比如“第22条军规”。以牙还牙。那是你的最爱。我的最爱。这是他第二次说它了。以牙还牙。还有，两击，我打你，你倒地。太棒了。
It was just so good. This leads me into my second time code, Angela. Okay. 13 minutes, 27 seconds. Well, I have one at 1325. All right, what's yours? Let's see. Well, this is at 1325,
真是太好了。这引出了我的第二个时间码，安吉拉。好的。13分27秒。嗯，我有一个在13分25秒。好吧，你的是什么？让我们看看。嗯，这是在13分25秒，
you see who actually goes to the dojo because you see everyone pile into the elevator and it is Phyllis, Pam, Meredith, Oscar, Creed, Kevin, Jim, Michael and Dwight. And who does not go to the dojo, Angela, Stanley, Toby, Kelly, and Ryan. Is that true? So you did not go to,
你看到谁真正去了道场，因为你看到每个人挤进电梯，那是菲利斯、帕姆、梅雷迪思、奥斯卡、克里德、凯文、吉姆、迈克尔和德怀特。谁没有去道场，安吉拉，斯坦利、托比、凯利和瑞安。那是真的吗？所以你没有去，
did you not film that day when we went? I had the day off. Oh my gosh. Yeah, it was decadent. Oh my goodness. So when I talk about being at the dojo, you're gonna hear what you missed out on. Yeah when I talk about being at the dojo, you're going to hear what you missed out on.
我们去的那天你没拍吗？我那天休息。天哪。是的，太颓废了。天哪。所以当我谈论在道场时，你会听到你错过了什么。是的，当我谈论在道场时，你会听到你错过了什么。
Yeah, I have no idea. And you know, the thinking was that Angela and Stanley would not participate in this. This is like shenanigans and they are literally there to do work and clock in and clock out. And so Angela and Stanley are really two of the big bah humbugs of the office. Toby and Kelly wouldn't go, or Ryan because as you know and I know they were writers and they needed to be in the writer's room and this was an opportunity for them to get some work done. Yes, it's so true. Well, when we all pile in the elevator,
是的，我不知道。你知道，当时的想法是安吉拉和斯坦利不会参加这个。这就像恶作剧，他们真的是去工作，打卡上班，打卡下班。所以安吉拉和斯坦利真的是办公室里两个大扫兴鬼。托比和凯利不会去，或者瑞安，因为正如你所知，我也知道，他们是编剧，他们需要待在编剧室里，这对他们来说是一个完成一些工作的机会。是的，太真实了。嗯，当我们都挤进电梯时，
I don't know why I'm so tickled by it, but at 13 minutes and 27 seconds, just watch Kevin's face as the elevator doors close. Okay. It just makes me laugh. He's got this little mischievous look on his face. He's very excited to see what's going to happen. Totally like a little kid who got to leave school.
我不知道为什么我被它逗乐了，但在13分27秒，看着电梯门关上时凯文的脸。好的。它只是让我笑。他脸上带着这种调皮的表情。他非常兴奋地想看看会发生什么。完全像一个可以离开学校的小孩。
Oh, that's so cute. I love it. All right. Well, Angela, I'm going to tell you some stuff. The day that we shot at the dojo, it was really hot. I was going to say, were you guys all hot and sweaty? Yes. And the air conditioning in our trailers wasn't working.
哦，太可爱了。我喜欢它。好吧。嗯，安吉拉，我要告诉你一些事情。我们拍摄道场的那天，真的很热。我本来想说，你们都又热又出汗吗？是的。我们拖车里的空调坏了。
Oh. So remember on the Dundies when they had ants? This time, they had no air conditioning, and they were their metal. So it was kind of like changing your clothes in a sauna. And we were just super sweaty, all of us and gross. And I had to wear a sweater because we had established my beige sweater earlier in the office. And I remember thinking, oh my God, I am so sweaty and stinky and John has to pick me up.
哦。所以记得在邓迪奖时他们有蚂蚁吗？这次，他们没有空调，而且是金属的。所以这有点像在桑拿房里换衣服。我们都超级出汗，我们所有人，很恶心。我不得不穿一件毛衣，因为我们在办公室里早些时候确定了我的米色毛衣。我记得当时想，哦，天哪，我太出汗了，太臭了，约翰不得不抱起我。
This is a thing that I think people don't think about. You know, anytime I would have a scene where I would have to whisper at someone or you'd have to kiss, I would brush my teeth like three times and chew gum and eat a mint before. And anytime when you have to be close to someone, I would be very aware of my potential body odor. Yeah. At least our show wasn't a show with a bunch of close talkers. Because you watch an episode of The Sopranos, they get in each other's faces. They're like, listen here.
这是一件我认为人们不会想到的事情。你知道，任何时候我有需要对某人耳语或需要接吻的戏，我都会刷三次牙，嚼口香糖，吃薄荷糖。任何时候当你需要靠近某人时，我会非常注意我潜在的体味。是的。至少我们的节目不是一个有很多“近距离交谈者”的节目。因为你看一集《黑道家族》，他们凑到对方脸上。他们就像，听着。
And they're right up to each other's face. Like, at least we didn't have that. That's true. But when I watch those scenes, because we're actors and we know, I think like, oh my god, there's no way they don't know what they had for lunch. Because that is some close talking. Well when Jim lifts Pam up at the dojo at 14 minutes 11 seconds, we got a lot of questions
他们直接凑到对方脸上。就像，至少我们没有那样。那是真的。但当我看到那些场景时，因为我们是演员，我们知道，我想，哦，天哪，他们不可能不知道午餐吃了什么。因为那是近距离交谈。嗯，当吉姆在14分11秒在道场抱起帕姆时，我们收到了很多问题
about this scene. I have questions so go. Well in Office Olympics, Angela has her bit about Pam Pong. Yes. And that's kind of the first time that Pam is made aware that someone else is aware. People are noticing. Yes. And now in this scene, Meredith clocks the interaction between Pam and Jim and that is what freaks out Pam. Also your shirt came up and you could see your belly. Now I remember as your friend that week, you saying to me, oh my gosh, oh my gosh,
关于这场戏。我有问题，所以说吧。嗯，在《办公室奥运会》里，安吉拉有关于“帕姆乒乓”的梗。是的。那是帕姆第一次意识到有人注意到了。人们注意到了。是的。现在在这场戏里，梅雷迪思注意到了帕姆和吉姆之间的互动，这就是让帕姆抓狂的原因。还有你的衬衫上来了，你可以看到你的肚子。现在作为你的朋友，那周，你对我说，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，
people are gonna see my belly. Cause it said, you know, it picks up and your shirt kind of comes up and you were nervous about it. Yeah, that was all, that was, so that was a fan question. Anthony asked, was it meant for your shirt to pull up when Jim lifted you or did it happen on accident
人们会看到我的肚子。因为它说，你知道，它向上，你的衬衫有点上来，你对此很紧张。是的，那全是，那是，所以那是一个粉丝问题。安东尼问，吉姆抱起你时衬衫上来是故意的，还是意外发生的，
and you went with it? It was in the script that my shirt would come up a little bit and that was all to make it even more of a vulnerable thing for Pam, that she was literally exposed. Yeah, something that you were really embarrassed about. Yes. And wow, I wish my stomach looked like that today. I watched that scene. I was like, why was I not wearing midriff tops every day when I looked like that? I know, I knew you were gonna say that because I mean, listen, we've had babies
你顺其自然了？剧本里写了我的衬衫会稍微上来一点，那都是为了让帕姆更脆弱，她真的暴露了。是的，你对此感到非常尴尬的事情。是的。哇，我真希望我今天的肚子看起来像那样。我看了那场戏。我想，为什么我看起来像那样的时候没有每天穿露脐上衣？我知道，我知道你会这么说，因为我的意思是，听着，我们生了孩子
and everything changes after that. And you're, I mean, you look phenomenal today, Jenna. You look phenomenal then, but I know I remember our bellies before babies. I remember. Well, I am kind of glad that it was scripted that you see my belly because I've got it on film now that at one time in my life, I had a cute little belly and belly button. So thank you, Jean and Lee for that.
一切在那之后都变了。而且你，我的意思是，你今天看起来棒极了。你当时看起来也棒极了，但我知道我记得我们生孩子前的肚子。我记得。嗯，我有点高兴剧本写了你会看到我的肚子，因为我现在有电影记录了，我生命中曾经有过一个可爱的小肚子和肚脐。所以谢谢吉恩和李。
At 13 minutes, 56 seconds, that's my third time code, Angela, there is a poster in the background of this interaction between Jim and Pam. So we're all watching Jim and Pam, but in the background there is a poster on the wall and it is one of my favorite things. It was like a favorite thing of all of us when we got to the dojo. This was a set decoration poster that Jean and Lee wrote that set decoration had printed and put on the wall. It is the 10 rules of karate.
在13分56秒，那是我的第三个时间码，安吉拉，在吉姆和帕姆互动的背景里有一张海报。所以我们都在看吉姆和帕姆，但在背景里墙上有一张海报，这是我最喜欢的东西之一。当我们到达道场时，这是我们所有人的最爱。这是一张布景装饰海报，吉恩和李写了，布景装饰组打印出来贴在墙上。它是“空手道的10条规则”。
Okay. All right. According to this dojo, and I'm going to read them to you. Okay. They're amazing. Number one, obey your parents. Okay. Number two, no junk food. Number three, do your homework. Number four, keep your room clean. Number five, maintain an indomitable spirit. Number six, don't fight with your siblings.
好的。好吧。根据这个道场，我要读给你们听。好的。它们太棒了。第一条，服从你的父母。好的。第二条，没有垃圾食品。第三条，做你的家庭作业。第四条，保持你的房间干净。第五条，保持不屈不挠的精神。第六条，不要和你的兄弟姐妹打架。
Seven, practice, practice, practice. Eight, treat others the way you would like to be treated. Nine, be loyal to your country. And 10, have fun." So Lee told me he still has this poster. He asked to have it. He said they spent way too long writing these goals. I bet they spent like hours like cracking themselves up.
第七条，练习，练习，练习。第八条，像你希望被对待的那样对待别人。第九条，忠于你的国家。第十条，玩得开心。”所以李告诉我他仍然有这张海报。他要求拥有它。他说他们花的时间太长来写这些目标了。我敢打赌他们花了几个小时像把自己逗乐一样。
It's amazing to me because I feel like it is this little detail that really hammers home that Dwight takes classes in a studio meant for children. Children, do your homework. These are kid-based rules. Yeah. And of course, you see that. You see that he's in a class with a bunch of 11-year-olds.
这对我来说太神奇了，因为我觉得这是一个小细节，真正强调了德怀特在为儿童准备的工作室里上课。孩子们，做你们的家庭作业。这些是基于孩子的规则。是的。当然，你看到了。你看到他和一群11岁的孩子在一起上课。
But I just think that is brilliant. Brilliant writing that poster. Okay, so that was their version of the rules of karate, right? There's this thread on Reddit where people go back and forth. They were like, but Dwight says karate and then there's taekwondo this and there's this and this. So a little bit that the martial arts didn't quite line up in that dojo. Yeah, I think that makes sense too.
但我只是觉得那太棒了。那张海报写得太棒了。好吧，所以那是他们版本的空手道规则，对吧？Reddit上有一个帖子，人们来回讨论。他们说，但德怀特说空手道，然后有跆拳道这个，有那个。所以那个道场里的武术不太一致。是的，我觉得那也说得通。
I mean, Dwight is not maybe studying a pure form of any one martial art. Right. I have to talk about the fact that at 14 minutes, 11 seconds, I think that Pam is sending Jim mixed signals. Of course she is. And I totally judged her a little bit. I know. Because she was being really flirty.
我的意思是，德怀特可能没有学习任何一种武术的纯粹形式。对。我必须谈谈在14分11秒，我认为帕姆在给吉姆发混合信号。当然她是。我完全有点评判她。我知道。因为她当时真的很调情。
And then when Meredith noticed, it wasn't until Meredith noticed. That's right. That then she like pushed him away. And then the look on John's face, he does such a fantastic job of looking wounded and confused and not really, he was so happy, but now he's like, now what happened?
然后当梅雷迪思注意到时，直到梅雷迪思注意到。那是对的。然后她就像把他推开了。然后约翰脸上的表情，他做得太棒了，看起来受伤和困惑，并不是真的，他当时那么开心，但现在他就像，现在发生了什么？
He did such a great job because Pam is sending him mixed signals. She really is. But I mean, that's complicated unrequited love for you. I know. What are you gonna do? She's conflicted. She's conflicted. She's conflicted.
他做得太棒了，因为帕姆在给他发混合信号。她确实是。但我的意思是，那是复杂的单相思。我知道。你要做什么？她很矛盾。她很矛盾。她很矛盾。
When Michael pins down Dwight at the dojo and is winning the fight, our director of photography, Randall Einhorn, who used to work on Survivor, so I want to say literally nothing surprises this man. He is a total pro. He never broke. He lost it. He lost it. He was laughing so hard that he had to take the camera off his shoulder
当迈克尔在道场压制德怀特并赢得战斗时，我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩，他过去在《幸存者》工作，所以我可以说真的没有什么能让这个人感到惊讶。他是一个完全的专业人士。他从不笑场。他失控了。他失控了。他笑得太厉害了，以至于他不得不把摄像机从肩膀上拿下来
and hold it out with his arm so that it wouldn't shake. He had tears, like, streaming down his face. It's the hardest I've ever seen him laugh. Yeah, that's saying something because he was like a statue. Him and Oscar Nunez never break. I have a question for you. Lance, when I was speaking to him, said to his knowledge the fight was not choreographed and that he really believed that the stuff that Michael, that Steve was doing to reign as Dwight, like holding him down
用手臂把它伸出去，这样它就不会晃动。他有眼泪，就像，顺着他的脸流下来。这是我见过他笑得最厉害的一次。是的，这说明了一些问题，因为他就像一尊雕像。他和奥斯卡·努涅斯从不笑场。我有个问题要问你。兰斯，当我和他交谈时，说据他所知，战斗没有编排，他真的相信迈克尔做的那些事，史蒂夫对雷恩作为德怀特做的那些事，比如压制他
and trying to spit on him and all of that, that Steve improvised that. I asked Lee about that. His memory is that they did bring in a stunt coordinator to work with them on set one day during a break. Yeah. So Lance wouldn't have been there for that. That's right. And so- But that person did not go to the dojo.
并试图向他吐口水等等，史蒂夫是即兴创作的。我问了李关于那个。他的记忆是他们确实在休息期间有一天带了一位特技协调员在片场和他们一起工作。是的。所以兰斯当时不会在那里。那是对的。所以——但那个人没有去道场。
Did not go to the dojo. The day that you actually did it, they were not present. And so on the day, he said they just like Steve and Rain and Ken Quapis just came up with a bunch of stuff like the typewriter stuff and just he said he doesn't remember how many takes they did, but it was a lot. But he said it was also really hot and those guys got really tired doing all the fake fighting. You can tell because they're winded when they're speaking to each other. They are. It's true.
没有去道场。你真正做的那天，他们不在场。所以在那天，他说他们只是像史蒂夫和雷恩和肯·夸皮斯只是想出了一堆东西，比如打字机的东西，他说他不记得他们拍了多少次，但很多。但他还说当时真的很热，那些家伙做所有的假打斗真的很累。你可以看出来，因为他们说话时气喘吁吁。他们是。这是真的。
Did you clock Phyllis's disposable camera in the scene where she's taking pictures and it's a disposable camera? Don't you wish we had those pictures? Who has those? Someone must. Yeah. Phil Shea? Phil Shea.
你注意到菲利斯在那个场景里的拍立得相机了吗，她正在拍照，那是一个拍立得相机？你不希望我们有那些照片吗？谁有那些？肯定有人有。是的。菲尔·谢？菲尔·谢。
I don't know. All right. So after this humiliating defeat, we go back to the office and we see a scene from Michael's office that goes down into the parking lot and he tries to call Ryan on his cell phone. That was a different office than the usual Michael's office. You totally, like it's completely different. Yes. So we had two Michael's offices. We had one Michael's office that was on our set and it had just like a scrim backdrop behind the window that was kind of blurry and it was just like old-fashioned fake
我不知道。好吧。所以在这场羞辱性的失败之后，我们回到办公室，我们看到迈克尔办公室的一场戏，一直到停车场，他试图用手机给瑞安打电话。那是一个与通常迈克尔办公室不同的办公室。你完全，就像它完全不同。是的。所以我们有两个迈克尔的办公室。我们有一个迈克尔的办公室，它在我们的片场，窗户后面有一个模糊的背景，就像老式的假
out the window kind of thing. But whenever we had to shoot a scene where Michael was actually looking out of his window into the parking lot, we would move over to the writers' offices. And they literally would shoot in a writer's office. Yes. And I was trying to remember, was it Mike Schur's office or Paul Lieberstein's office. Yes, and I was trying to remember was it Mike Schur's office or Paul Lieberstein's office? One of the two of them worked in Michael's office and it was loosely decorated as Michael's office and then when it was time to shoot they would get kicked out of their office and set dressing would come in and zhuzh it up and then they would have to use that to shoot and they couldn't write in their office that day. But the walls are like kind of a green color.
窗外的那种东西。但每当我们不得不拍一场迈克尔真的从窗户往停车场看的戏时，我们就会搬到编剧办公室。他们真的会在编剧办公室拍摄。是的。我试图回忆，是迈克·舒尔的办公室还是保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室。是的，我试图回忆是迈克·舒尔的办公室还是保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室？他们中的一个人在迈克尔的办公室工作，它被随意装饰成迈克尔的办公室，然后当需要拍摄时，他们会被赶出办公室，布景装饰组会进来装饰它，然后他们必须用那个来拍摄，那天他们不能在办公室里写东西。但墙壁是那种绿色的颜色。
Yes, that was always true. That don't match. I was like, guys, the walls are not the same. Well, it's funny too, because all the other writers could decorate their offices. Oh, Mindy's office was so decorated. Oh, for sure. Of course. Yeah. Of course. But you could have like personal photos up and posters on the wall, but they couldn't do it.
是的，那一直都是真的。那对不上。我就想，伙计们，墙面不一样。嗯，这很有趣，因为其他编剧都可以装饰他们的办公室。哦，敏迪的办公室装饰得太漂亮了。哦，当然。那是肯定的。是的。当然。但你可以放个人照片和海报在墙上，但他们却不能。
I feel like it was Paul's. I think it was Paul's as well. That's my memory. If it wasn't Paul's, then Paul just really didn't make a lot of effort to decorate one of the two. I remember his office being pretty bare. So next up, Michael tells the rest of us to sign the forms. He's given up. For sure. At the end of the show, the people who actually signed the reports are Toby, Stanley, Angela, and Pam.
我觉得那是保罗的。我也认为是保罗的。这是我的记忆。如果不是保罗的，那保罗在装饰这两间办公室中的任何一间时真的没花什么心思。我记得他的办公室相当空旷。接下来，迈克尔告诉我们其他人去签表格。他放弃了。肯定的。在节目最后，真正签署报告的人是托比、斯坦利、安吉拉和帕姆。
And we were all grouped together at the reception desk, and I loved shooting that scene because everyone else had gone home for the day. Except for Dwight. That's right. Who was at his desk. But most of the office was gone, and that group of us, we were very rarely in little scenes together. Just us. And I have very
我们都聚在接待台，我喜欢拍摄那场戏，因为其他人都已经下班回家了。除了德怀特。没错。他还在他的办公桌前。但办公室里大部分人都走了，我们那一组人，很少有机会一起拍小场景。只有我们。而且我有非常
fond memories of shooting that. Me too. Me too. That was really, really fun. I have one thing that is a time code that was right before the end there. At 17 minutes 57 seconds, people are packing up for the day. Guess who's sitting across from Meredith? Who? Ryan. Yeah, that was his desk. But where was Creed? Creed didn't really have a desk yet. I don't know.
美好的拍摄回忆。我也是。我也是。那真的非常非常有趣。我有一个时间码，就在结尾之前。在17分57秒，人们正在收拾东西准备下班。猜猜谁坐在梅雷迪思对面？谁？瑞安。是的，那是他的桌子。但克里德在哪里？克里德当时还没有固定的桌子。我不知道。
When does Creed take over Ryan's desk and when does Ryan move back to the annex? These are good questions. I know. Did Ryan, well, eventually remember we turned that closet in the hallway into Ryan's office, I feel like. Yeah, for a little bit. That desk was kind of the catch-all, right?
克里德是什么时候接管瑞安的桌子，瑞安又是什么时候搬回附属办公室的？这些都是好问题。我知道。瑞安，嗯，最终记得我们把走廊里的那个壁橱变成了瑞安的办公室，我觉得。是的，有一小会儿。那张桌子算是杂物堆，对吧？
I feel like I've seen Devin there, I've seen Ryan there, I've seen Creed there. When does it become Creed's desk? Also in this episode at the end, when people are filing out, we see an appearance of Luann. Oh, there's Luann. Luann.
我觉得我见过德文在那儿，见过瑞安在那儿，也见过克里德在那儿。它是什么时候变成克里德的桌子的？另外在这一集的结尾，当人们陆续离开时，我们看到了卢安的身影。哦，那是卢安。卢安。
Luann was one of our stand-ins slash extras. Who would normally sit in the annex and people always say, who is that? So Luann walks by. That's right. I feel like the two things I wanna tell you guys we're gonna be dedicated to tracking in this rewatch is Mindy's hair and when does Creed get his desk?
卢安是我们的一位替身兼临时演员。她通常坐在附属办公室，人们总是问，那是谁？所以卢安走过。没错。我觉得有两件事我想告诉你们，我们要在这次重温中专门追踪：敏迪的发型，以及克里德是什么时候得到他的桌子的？
Okay, so just know that. Someone out there probably already knows. They're gonna write in and say, you guys, Creed sits there in episode. Tell us. Solve this mystery. Okay. Michael takes Dwight into the conference room here at the end and he says he's been testing them all day and he promotes Dwight to assistant regional manager. He gets no announcement, no raise and no new office, but Dwight is so happy. He whites out to the on all of his business cards.
好吧，只要知道这一点就行。外面可能已经有人知道了。他们会写信来说，你们这些家伙，克里德在第几集坐在那儿。告诉我们。解开这个谜团。好的。迈克尔在结尾把德怀特带进会议室，他说他整天都在测试他们，然后他提拔德怀特为助理区域经理。他没有得到任何公告，没有加薪，也没有新办公室，但德怀特非常高兴。他把他所有的名片上的内容都涂掉了。
It's so pure and sweet. I know. It's so sweet, although Michael's like, it's not really a real thing, but it doesn't really matter. Dwight isn't hearing that part. Dwight doesn't care. He doesn't hear any words except assistant regional manager. And then this leads us to the famous Michael talking headline, would I rather be feared
这太纯真可爱了。我知道。太可爱了，尽管迈克尔说，这并不是真的，但这并不重要。德怀特没听进去那部分。德怀特不在乎。他除了“助理区域经理”之外什么话都没听进去。然后这就引出了迈克尔那句著名的独白，我更愿意被
or loved? Easy. Both. I want people to be afraid of how much they love me. I have seen that stitched on pillows. I have seen that on shirts. I want people to be afraid of how much they love me. Good writers.
敬畏还是被爱？很简单。两者都要。我希望人们因为他们有多爱我而感到害怕。我见过这句话被绣在枕头上。我见过它印在衬衫上。我希望人们因为他们有多爱我而感到害怕。好编剧。
Such good writing. And that was the fight. That was the fight. So next week, we will be back with The Client. The Client. This is maybe my favorite season two episode, although there's also the injury. I love the injury. You love the injury, Jenna. You wore a shirt like that you've bought online of the injury. I I know. You love the injury, Jenna. You wore a shirt, like that you've bought online of the injury. I bought a shirt from Etsy of a grilled foot for a long time. Yeah, that you would wear. You would wear it a lot.
写得真好。那就是那场争吵。那就是那场争吵。所以下周，我们将带着《客户》回来。《客户》这可能是我最喜欢的第二季剧集，尽管还有《受伤》。我喜欢《受伤》。你喜欢《受伤》，珍娜。你穿过一件你在网上买的关于《受伤》的衬衫。我，我知道。你喜欢《受伤》，珍娜。你穿过一件你在网上买的关于《受伤》的衬衫。我很久以前从Etsy买了一件印有烤脚图案的衬衫。是的，你会穿它。你会经常穿它。
It was like one of your favorite shirts. Jeez, did it bother you? It didn't. Did I wear it too often? No, it didn't, but it just made me laugh. There was a day that you showed up in your shirt with the grilled foot, and I had a shirt that was like an inside joke on our show
那就像你最喜欢的衬衫之一。天哪，它困扰你了吗？没有。我穿得太频繁了吗？没有，但它只是让我发笑。有一天你穿着那件印有烤脚图案的衬衫出现，而我穿了一件关于我们节目的内部笑话的衬衫
of Creed as an action figure in Hong Kong. Uh-huh. And we both. Did we realize we were maybe too big a fan? We're like, what are we doing? We're just walking around in shirts from our show. So next week we will be talking about not the injury, but the client.
是克里德在香港的动作人偶。嗯哼。我们俩。我们是否意识到我们可能太狂热了？我们就像，我们在做什么？我们只是穿着我们节目的衬衫走来走去。所以下周我们将讨论的不是《受伤》，而是《客户》。
We'll see you then. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到时候见。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。